it's monday
august 30th
2021
the world is on fire or this state thank
you shredder
this state is on fire
the country's under siege from
hurricanes
california
governor is about to be by be recalled
and replaced by some dude that believes
that uh
there should be no minimum wage
but we're still here baby it's h3 july
and we're not talking about any of that
[ __ ] because here
it's good vibes it's monday let's go
today is our first ever h3 tv on the on
our youtube channel this can be our new
monday schedule
what is h3tv
nice hoodie ab
thank you thank you
thank hoodie
jerry garcia oh damn dude check that out
oh
how's it feel
it feels great like all teddy fresh
big great quality
you can't argue before that's what she
said
[Applause]
no one ever said that to me
um
this city is also available on
teddyfresh.com thank you thank you
today's episode sponsored by meundies
babble and honey so h3tv
is our more relaxed live episode where
we are going to be taking calls we are
going to be taking suggestions this is
our audience interaction
super event i like that
and how do you so dan how does it work
people who want to
call in or make suggestions
um are it's via discord or do we also
have our hot meme number we have our hot
meme number yeah collins will be via the
telephone and if you want to call
there it is
let the conversation see the
conversation begin if you want to
suggest videos that would be via discord
for our members yes there is an h3
tv
uh react suggestion channel in the
discord
that is where i will have that open
during the show i'll be taking a look
i'll be checking out the vids and uh i
like that send them over to ethan
i like that let the conversation i say
let the conversation begin yeah um i
don't know why but youtube doesn't seem
to allow links well i i do know why
because it's a total [ __ ] show but
but the discord does discord does you
know so there you go but we've got some
good stuff at the top here to talk about
while we populate some good calls and
stuff
i said that already thank you dan
thank you for your responsibilities but
by the way i don't i don't see the call
thing open on my computer is that open
here
oh uh i have it running via my computer
oh but you like to see you can pipe it
in you can pipe it in i can pipe it in
for today i'll pipe it in yeah you pipe
it i'll do a little piping well i hope
everyone had a great weekend
i did actually my my sphincter has been
through lots of trauma though
still
it's in recovery okay you're
in rehab i'm in rehab i did go twice
already since i got to the office at
least you got that bidet game going yeah
the bidet saved my life over the
christine
yeah
dude okay so first of all james corden
i don't know why i just don't like this
guy and he seems nice right like he
seems fine i don't know dude is do i
have any legitimate reason to not like
him other than just like
well i believe he actually has somewhat
of a bad reputation
in the industry really for what
just being kind of a domineering
boss and everything kind of similar to
the way that everybody kind of
knew about ellen before at all
james gordon yeah i've heard lots of
stuff about him before but i mean it's
all rumors and everything oh boogie
actually came out with a pretty funny
tweet he said this is why people are
leaving california
funny i'll give it up to him for that
one
yeah um
so james court what are they promoted
james corden cinderella
this is the worst thing i swear to god i
feel like he he essayed me
i wanted to put he essayed me but dan
kai botched it in the title but i was
like i was like dude he did
watch this and tell me you don't feel
assaulted by james gordon
watch this [ __ ]
and try not to get angry
they stopped traffic
this is when it goes too far i mean the
whole thing's too far but like hey
what's up dude you ready for this boom
boom boom boom uh uh dude
uh uh
to be honest if i was there i'd be like
i don't really
dude i don't really even know who you
guys are
i didn't even know who you are
this is the worst imagine getting off of
like a 10 or 12 hour shift trying to go
home
and all of a sudden your car
is stopped and james corden is in a rat
outfit just thrusting out your window
drive you know you know i get the
feeling this took place in the morning
and people are trying to get to work
you know god forbid that he ever does
i'm ready to get a uh vehicular
manslaughter i was about to say if i saw
that yeah
i'm ready to go to jail for this baby
james corbin
shaking his dick at me at 8am no
boogie's right i'm leaving the state
i'll tell you what if if newsome gets
recalled i'm uh bro i don't know bro
no minimum wait okay i'm not getting
into that
oh i did want to say also
before we get too deep in new show
is starting next week
this is a little weird but it's gonna be
on sundays the new show
[Applause]
so starting next week on sunday you're
gonna get a new duo a new partner
a new partner and i think we're all very
excited about who this is right like i
feel like it's pretty hype it's gonna be
cool it's gonna be cool
i'm very excited
should i say who it is nope should i
tease it at all
surprise should i let people guess if
you want to guess if you want to call in
and guess i'll entertain
that's interesting i'll do like if
people want to call in and do like uh
seven like five questions or whatever
[Music]
people figure it out real quick you're
gonna figure it out i think you get one
five is like yeah five's easy
one call one question i don't even think
they need a question i feel like
they might
well sure
i've seen that
i've seen some people correctly guess it
but not a lot there's been a lot of
guesses though
somebody's bound to get it
i've seen a lot of guesses too that i'm
like
really well we it's a huge get i'm just
gonna let the cat back it's hillary
clinton
i see a lot of people in the chat saying
keemstar oh
the new keemstar podcast
can you imagine
i can't imagine because i'm in the
process of setting it all up for next
week it's not a dude it's not even like
okay like it's not even like keemstar
like oh he's a bad dude and i don't want
to i don't want to like co-sign him it's
that he's not funny or entertaining like
look at what he did on adam ross's
stream do you think that guy's capable
of even being entertaining well i was
entertained by that clip but yeah
not something i'm looking to endure
every week but like trisha say what you
will about trisha but she's entertaining
as hell oh absolutely keemstar on the
other hand no
yeah he doesn't have it i feel very
foolish yeah
you should somebody said gerard way
gerard way oh
[Laughter]
yep you got it that's it anyway do you
guys feeling offended by this as much as
i am
i hate it i hate it a lot
you know and also you know what was the
biggest reason i don't like james corden
too
bro this [ __ ] is unforgivable
like let's not forget about this
[ __ ] it's unforgivable i did forget
about that james corder was in cats
thank you for reminding me he did that
to us as well i'm here live that's not
i'm not a cat well he is a cat and this
is unforgivable crime against humanity
oh
somebody said little tracy as the guest
little tracy
yeah remember
oh god that's a that's a blast from the
past did i have like beef with him on
twitter or something well not really
you mentioned we mentioned him on the
podcast and he got really upset oh he's
gonna tweet at me again
he tweets me like death threats
all right and then of course is wait
this isn't a vic burger but somebody put
this together so here you go i think it
is if somebody just reposted it i saw
him posted originally oh yeah so
you know this is unacceptable folks
look at that
i'm gonna come
i mean from one chubby legend to another
though
i'm sure i've done that move
actually i definitely have done that
move you did a whole video of that movie
actually
does that make you really think but at
least people have to click my video to
watch it they have to consent on the
click
right you have to click and watch that
to the thrusting nobody well i did just
click the watcher but the person in the
car didn't
speaking of hurricanes al roker was bla
this poor man al roker man he's been
through so much why do we do this to him
why do we do this for al roker i wonder
if he insists actually i wonder if
i can already tell from the thumbnail
that this is pretty epic
you know al roker used to be first of
all shout out to the skinny legend this
guy used to be
really big and he lost it all man it's
inspiring
uh huge sorry forgive me but i just
tried to find a before and after huge
sorry
he was huge i mean
can i say that here's the
was a big deal
yeah no he was a big boy
so his weight loss is inspiring skinny
legend out there
but yeah so you know he's missing that
weight in this video let me tell you
i wish him need some anchoring yeah
yeah so
you know america just got hit by
the biggest hurricane to hit
louisiana since 1850
this was a monster hurricane
and for some reason there's just a
fetish for sending reporters out there
to
get battered by it here it is welcome
back we're now going to get an update
right now on hurricane ida from our
phone oh my god
he's already in new orleans which is in
look at this storm and al this looks
like a monster storm that's coming what
can you tell us
are you kidding me all right sorry i
guess we lost communication
dude you gotta you can't be serious
right now
we are looking at imminent landfall
he's about to get sucked out to ocean
150 miles per hour
our our lights are right now forecast
but we expect landfall in the next
couple of hours they will be at 155
miles per hour storm surges upwards of
15 yeah he stood there on purpose you
could sit on the grass
i know once it zooms out it's like just
step a few feet to the side
150 mile per hour winds it's basically
a 15 mile wide f3 tornado that's what's
coming in i 100 wouldn't be standing
that close to the water he's about to
get sucked out to sea and so
as this system comes in people have
hunkered that's what i mean though they
are doing their best i wonder if he
insists on still getting out there and
doing it like that's my favorite
category one storm and a category five
i'm not gonna lie i like watching it's
quite a special 130 times more powerful
so we are waiting for this i'm blown
away by the audio quality it's going to
slowly make it think about that
yeah they've been doing this for you for
decades so they've got to figure it out
huh
i sent another roker classic in the uh
here's jordan here's one below i'm gonna
click this and i'll watch yours
and folks on twitter well first of all
oh this is the same one i volunteered to
come out here this is what i do oh he's
saying i love him
who i am
any of you guys willing to go stand in
front of a hurricane i thought we could
be fun for the h3 podcast
fortunately for us we don't get any
hurricanes here in california we'll have
to send zach out to florida or something
zach you down hell yeah
i would actually do that i'm afraid
you'll actually get hurt though because
they they like know what they're doing
kind of
zach will end up dying
just pay for my funeral
i cover your funeral what kind of what
kind of funeral are we talking about
like how extravagant i want to be buried
in a kiss coffin
so okay i mean just a caught like a wood
coffin but what do you mean kiss like
kiss the band no i know but like how
deep what does it look like just painted
yeah they actually came out with their
own brand coffins oh for real yeah
yeah i'll buy you one of those cool
yeah i'm uh that'd be uh that'd be an
honor it's called the kiss casket just
casket excuse me i can buy it now and
just keep it in the office
i'm gonna sleep some pics send me that
maybe he's got it up he's he'll send it
to you
kiss is selling their own coffin huh
yeah they've been doing it for years i
mean they've merchandised everything
kiss condoms well yeah i mean once you
get to coffin that's pretty much the end
of the line
it's casket
owning a little license kiss cat oh that
is [ __ ] sick it's hype as [ __ ] right
i mean like i get it here's the thing i
get that you like the band but do you
really want to spend eternity with them
[ __ ] yeah i love kiss
oh what about your feet
[ __ ] cool dude you gotta go out in
style i've never heard you talk about
kiss before yeah you know i'm a huge
news fan
yo aliens are gonna dig this [ __ ] up in
like ten thousand years and be like what
the [ __ ] they're gonna be this guy this
guy [ __ ] he rocks [ __ ] it's got good
music taste no they'll be like humanity
is
[ __ ] scary and weird
you should get buried in a nickelback
nickelback casket yeah oh he signed it
you want a signed one sure why not
maybe i can bury him in there with you
go out in style dude would you let me
bury you with him what the hell with
this guy jeans whatever his name is
uh yeah sure all right
bury you with the whole band yeah there
we go
how much is this thing
you're on the site does it say it
doesn't say it on the site you have to
call
i'd say it's easily you know tens of
thousands of dollars
coffins are expensive actually but yeah
let's get i do want a price quote on
that before i send zach out
um dark dude here you sent me a roker
classic here i got it up already okay
thank you over on the screen here we go
florida october 24th 2005
a category three hurricane named wilma
shows off the incredible force of its
wind
in fact nbc's al roker is knocked right
off his feet
oh there's someone carrying live shots
for the today show
he's
he gets beaten up it's left to the
cameraman to keep
like away don't you wish you had your
weight back yeah oh that's what you guys
were joking about
it's roker versus wilma but with wilma's
winds up to 125 miles
wow
it looks fun i mean i love what they're
doing out there it has it has no
value to any discourse or news or
weather reporting at all
i don't know
yeah i really don't know i mean it's
exciting
i guess add some pizzazz to the uh to
the weather report
so we got any calls i can't see anything
i'm sure we must have something uh i'll
check in yeah you could just you could
just pipe a man yeah dan and introduce
them i trust you
okay
oh dude oh my god drake is tripping
balls
is he now this guy's tripping this is
the cover of his new
album
um
certified lover boar it's a bunch of
emojis of pregnant women
uh 12 of them
and i'm is he saying
well because i remember um
what's his name there's a celeb
nick carter
that he that is absolutely so he's he's
doing this thing legitimately where he's
trying to knock up as many women as
possible for like because i guess he's
he's like muslim now and he he thinks
that he needs to make as many kids as
possible he had like carter
oh nick cannon nick cannon
look into that tell me how many k how
many girls did you get pregnant this
year alone it's like five dogs
so wondering if that's what drake's up
to
nick cannon has had four babies in a
year since his billboard magazine
different mom in july he's crazy his
seventh child and first he's like
genghis khan he's trying to like
he's like trying to take over
in 10 years the whole country is going
to be populated by nick cannon's kids
i have an update on the kiss casket oh i
just spoke to a very kind southern
gentleman who gave me the whole lowdown
yeah it's three thousand dollars oh what
three thousand dollars he asked if i was
a collector or if i
was actually using it for death
because the initial badge were assigned
uh i said death yes and what did he say
he said he said six hundred dollars to
ship out to l.a
because i was wondering if you'd be like
well these aren't actually good for
death oh no he said they're um
they're very nice black velvet and
stitched in the pillow says end of the
road
this is too dark dude
wait hold on this is your idea you were
gung-ho like five minutes now it's come
to fruition i mean this is just wait
three thousand seems like
we're suspiciously low you sure you got
the right number dude
yeah one eight hundred kissing i thought
nice caskets ran like ten g's yeah
that's what i thought as well
dining
and dying ain't cheap man in america
nothing's cheap not even death you can't
even [ __ ] die for free in this
country man
gotta pay to die
yeah so what do you make of this album
cover is he's just trying to knock up
what does this mean
maybe he's saying it's like
baby making music or something
do not come well it's called lover boy
so i'm assuming
certified lover boy if it's called
certified lover boy it sounds like he's
saying i got 12 baby mamas
i mean he did have a kid that he hid for
a while so i don't know how many other
are out there
true i went to a direct concert once and
he said something along the lines of uh
people always make fun of me for making
too many songs for women he's like hell
yeah i do and he said one day i'm going
to make an album just for women now this
was in 2013. i don't know if that has
anything to do with this but
let's continue to let look which is
gonna be a bunch of i don't see this
being like necessarily appealing to
women where it's like
i'ma get you pregnant and exit the
picture girl i'm gonna give you my
number
they're like yeah drake i'ma get you
pregnant and then not be a dad
what's your interpretation of this ian
as our resident hip-hop analyst
oh just real quick somebody in the chat
said uh one for each month wow maybe
that's it's it's symbolizing every month
of the year
ian i don't like i said i don't know
maybe it's just like that's
it's baby making music i don't know okay
maybe it's smooth music and he's like oh
people are gonna you know
they're gonna make babies
but i gotta say i don't love the emojis
man this is not that [ __ ] cool
you know like of all the art if you're
the biggest artist in the world i just
think like there's probably cooler art
to make
clap those cheeks than [ __ ] emojis
you know
but what the [ __ ] do i know i'm just
some [ __ ]
i think
um
he kind of did this before with like
this diamond emoji he used a stock photo
of a
diamond picture
maybe it's
then you can like promote the album over
text super easy it's like a marketing
thing
so then you can just
share around these pregnant women emojis
to promote his album and anyone can do
it you know oh so you can spam it under
people's replies and whatever
interesting so it's a little bit of a 3d
chess yeah
that might be horrible cover art
great
twitter
reach
um
i appreciate the diversity you know
he hit every spectrum on that emoji
on that emoji uh
race
so that's i mean we like that right guys
we like the diversity we like the
representation
yeah
sure
is there one missing because i want to
call him out like what do you mean no it
looks like it's yeah the bases are
covered pretty good
i mean not the uh emoji covers of the
crew if you want to oh so so ian you
want to so ian put together a little bit
a thing for us
if we all made our own album
which emojis
would represent us
so yeah so i i had everyone here send us
uh their most recent or most frequently
used emojis
and uh you can try and guess whose is
whose did you make one for me
no i didn't get yours if you
wait let me send you mine
okay
people are saying they want a donda
review from ian
i actually want a donder review too
because okay you you i'm gonna send you
this emoji you know give me an honest
donder review i don't want any like beer
i don't want any dancing around i mean
tell me really what you think about this
album
[Music]
i was saying earlier i think
out of everyone here besides a b who
listened to it i think i like it the
least
zach
you liked it right i actually do enjoy
it i hate it i hated it i thought it was
dog [ __ ]
don't kill me kanye fans
i agree i uh i thought some of the
samples were actually very clever the uh
synthesizer was really cool um
i actually enjoyed it believe it or not
uh
i think it's way too long
personally that i will agree with what
27 songs 26 songs what the [ __ ] dude
it's uh almost two hours
i think that the fat could be uh trimmed
a little bit i'm very tired
like halfway through oh the other thing
i was talking to ian about
was the album the album is not mixed
like it's
the mixing is it's almost like he made
it in a
in a in a janitor's closet yeah like
some sort of stadium or something yeah
but just the instrument levels are just
way off
also i'm a little confused by the whole
um
branding and tone what he was going for
i guess because
it's like about donda and his mother and
he has like some of my favorite songs
he's ever made
about his mother
they're called
like hey mama is one and there's one
called only one and there's one called
mama's boyfriend
and uh these are very heartfelt tributes
to his mother and this
just doesn't exist on this record at all
which i'm a little confused by
what exactly the songs are meant to mean
the one
clip he plays of his mother speaking is
him
uh
it's a clip of her talking about how
she's kanye's mom so the clip he plays
of his mother is just
her
talking about him it was more about him
yeah i don't know i'm a little confused
by the direction the direction of it uh
i'm not sure i'm not crazy about it i
i'm seeing a lot of people going
absolutely nuts about the album i'm
curious how they're going to react or
how often they'll revisit some of these
songs in uh a month or two i'm curious
if it will
still have this reception that people
are giving it you know stand the test of
time yeah
yeah that's a good thing there's like a
level of hype you have to wait
for the hype to settle and then
my my reaction to it was like
and it goes to what you were saying it
just it's it's poorly conceived it's not
thought out it's rushed the music is all
kind of from what i heard
there's very little it's all
kind of flat
kind of boring there's not a big
diversity
of sounds
and um
it just doesn't feel very inspired or
interesting or new it just feels lazy
and i didn't like it i was telling ian
um
one of the big themes of the record is
that organ sound
and it's just a lot of the tracks you
can't even
hear it it's not very prominent
so um
yeah
i think the more the star of the record
is mike dean as producer
than anything
it sounds like you [ __ ] up though
if you can't hear the organ sounds well
that's from a mixing standpoint yeah
am i mixing am i mixing it seems like
that guy [ __ ] up
i think uh i've been struggling to
understand zack's point of view all day
because i kind of grilled him about him
like which how many songs did you like
and he said he liked less than half the
songs i'm like how do you like the album
then that sounds like you don't like the
album well i get it i don't yeah i mean
but there's you can like singles
and not care for the album which it
sounds like like that seems to be the
discourse is like oh these five tracks
are great and it's like but it's 30
tracks long or whatever and if most of
it's boring then
it sounds like it's not very good well i
said i like 12 to 13 of the tracks and
that in itself is its own record because
this is a double album
so i like one half of the record i like
cd you could you could extract a good
album from this album right right
exactly we need zach's master
i can make a spotify playlist
yeah i think you could trim this down
and make a pretty good project but you'd
have to take out a big chunk of it and
rework some stuff because there are
great songs there's like a song called
moon that's incredible and there's a
handful of i'm seeing a lot of people
spam that song but then there's 25 other
songs
so
i don't know it needs to be cut down
yeah it seems like everyone has big
hopes for it being like this high level
concept album and it just was not that i
don't know what to say
yeah some of the discourse you know
some of these kanye people
are digging deep into the meaning and
like oh this the tracklist starts with
this song and it ends with this song and
it's his great journey of he starts
like the first song is called jail and
then the last song
it's him like ascending and reaching god
and all this i'm like he just decided
the tracklist like four days ago yeah
that was not the order for like a month
so then building this great narrative
about the sequencing and all of that
that's so on the fly
i'm like how can you you're
giving it credit that i don't
necessarily know it deserves it seems
very random spontaneous that's the
problem with his creative the way he's
created this album so publicly
changing the track list removing trash
removing people it removes the
mysteriousness removes the intention
behind a great album like you see
kendrick lamar he disappears for years
and he comes out with this super
polished beautiful album
and all that stuff's open for
interpretation because it's his
intention
is completely out of the picture where
kanye's just
dude it's a kid trying to [ __ ] finish
his homework at the last minute let's be
honest
sorry
do we have any calls
what do we got yeah we got a bunch um we
do we should theoretically take our
little ad break pretty soon here but
let's say you're ready let's take a call
first yeah yeah uh let's see
i got a bunch here
um somebody has a guest for the co-host
but also a little tracy anecdote
bring him on jason
see what jason has to say i'm gonna
bring him on
oh we have our first
jason you there jason hang on yeah
what's up ethan jason hang on one sec we
gotta we got our first emoji
so we supposed to guess who's this is
ian
yeah sorry i meant to link the whole
gallery i linked the wrong one okay we
can do this afterwards let's do it we
got jason here jason could play with us
yeah whatever
all right yeah
all right let's talk to jason jason
what's up who do you think it is
um only one guest one guest
okay only one guest okay all right i was
thinking it might be oliver tree
is it oliver tree
zack hit me with this nope not all of
her trees sorry
i did see a lot of people guessing
oliver though i don't think i could
possibly tie that guy down for a weekly
podcast that's true
man yeah exactly
do love the guy though i also
sorry i also have a inner uh a little
tracy story because um
i went to see him
i don't know i guess a couple years ago
now and i saw him at uh
some place in new york city and um it
was the night where on his instagram
live stream i didn't know about this
until after but on his instagram live he
threatened to uh
shoot up the whole venue oh sure
yo this guy what is the deal with this
guy man that is he's threatened to shoot
up his own
show
yeah and so he came out during like the
openers and he did like one song so like
everyone saw him and was like
losing it and then like he went to the
back i guess and had like some breakdown
and then a bunch of cops with m16s just
came in and like or whatever the what
the big ass guns they got yeah and they
pushed us all out and i i was wild
how was the song he performed
it was a
nice five out of ten i'd say nice five
man
did you get a refund yeah
no oh [ __ ]
well you did get an experience i will
say that yeah that's for sure yeah true
wow um before you let me go can i ask
zach a question
what's up
i want to know have you ever seen the
rain oh [ __ ] off
goddamn
[ __ ] got him
but like yeah it doesn't rain that much
in la so no it's beautiful weather here
you know a bit chilly out but you know
we're good thank you dude thank you that
was a good one i'll give it to you
that was a good thing thank you thank
you for your call
yeah i appreciate you thanks for calling
love you too stay golden stay golden
pony boy
have you he got you zack
so so
tell me about how that feels when he
does that i mean that that was that was
good i'll hand it to him okay all right
you don't feel like all uh
jinxed no no no no no that's gonna be
all the calls today
yeah i have a feeling that might be
so how's the sun have you ever seen the
rain i didn't know that was even a
client's climb clean gliding's clean
do you do that on purpose i really can't
tell a client's clean client klein water
please keep saying that yeah
you know it's funny i've actually like
blocked the word on my instagram page
so the people spam it with that which is
actually pretty funny to tell you the
truth
um
but yeah
what's this one you sent me the the
maledictions of gary klein i don't know
it just it's a fan song or something it
looked interesting what the hell is that
we should probably do um it's it's it
appears to be about gary
and i have some people cleaned it thumbs
up in it
uh no i haven't yet i'm just i'm trying
to just pull stuff it looks interesting
devices torture devices
wake up
and stab them
stab them
stab them
and then the whole everyone would blue
me they would blew me my family well i'm
with him i'm do you understand when i'm
a kid people are blowing my dad you
don't even they don't even know that
you're with him oh please what are you
saying what are you saying
they don't know i'm with them come on
[Music]
i don't think i actually ever
stabbed one oh stop no you literally
just said this is the swift like army
knife i used
i stopped it wasn't first i stopped it
when i saw him pull out the knife
[Music]
i'm having ptsd that was enough to cause
panic in the
adjoining areas
[Music]
to all of them
yeah this is pretty good man
this is how it feels to go to a baseball
game with my dad
i want to see this film
[Music]
this is me running away from the scene
of the crime right
i see he's he's gotten to you he's
poisoned your brain yours a little less
and mine not at all
so that's what i'm that's how i'm
understanding this all right
he is a legend
bravo cedric oh the disneyland on fire
that's a beautiful thumbnail too yeah
that is beautiful thank you for the
submission all right let's do some ads
real fast and we'll get back to the fun
yeah sure
first of all i gotta thank my boys at
meundies you know it's fall it's time to
replace
uh
your underwear
long past dude
you know let's be honest folks how many
of y'all got this internet or underwear
that's literally disintegrating
it's long past time to upgrade and be an
adult find that comfortable beautiful
underwear and me undies is the best
underwear that you're ever going to wear
it's the softest most breathable most
beautiful underwear that's ever going to
touch your skin
i love my undies honestly changed my
life as a fat guy i put those i put
those waistbands to the max
and you may not know what to look at me
but i'm 2xl
yeah i'm reaching the peaks of what is
possible
and underwear suspension and mandy's got
me covered bro
imagine the softest thing you've ever
felt now imagine the same thing but on
your butt
you're now thinking about me undies
they're designed by the country's top
softness scientists will be the softest
thing you've ever worn period
from me undies to loungewear their
fabrics are breathable light and almost
irresponsibly cozy really you might not
be able to stop lounging on the couch
you've been warned available in sizes
extra small through 4xl and a variety of
classic colors and iconic prints me and
these will have your back
and your butt all fall along for our
listeners we've got a great offer any
first time purchase you get 15 off and
free shipping mandy's also has the
problem free philosophy if you're not
satisfied with any product for any
reason
you get a full refund no caveats no
questions forget about it
and apparently they've got all kinds of
cool fall prints coming out head on over
to mandys.com h3tv
check them out 15 off your first order
free shipping 100
satisfaction guarantee that's
meundies.com
slash h3
some love making music too really great
new album
you guys want to learn new language well
you're going to with babble
you are lit whether you like it or not
when you're traveling to a destination
where you don't know the language it can
be challenging to accomplish the
simplest tasks
you know
absolutely
five years in israel
still can barely order food
don't be like me
with babel you won't be like me so
number one selling language learning app
through babel's bite-sized lessons
you're going to learn new language
skills that you can actually use in the
real world from greetings menus and
directions to gain a deeper
understanding of the culture babel is
the travel essential
yeah they've got a bunch of they've got
all the big uh
languages there man
pretty much whatever you would want it's
on there 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language apps use ai
for their lesson plans let's get out of
here with the robot [ __ ] but babel
uses lessons that were created by over
100 language experts their teaching
methods have been scientifically proven
to be effective and with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german
plus babble speech recognition
technology helps you improve your
pronunciation and accents there's so
many ways to learn with babel in
addition to lessons you can access
podcast games videos stories and even
live classes so start your new language
learning journey today with babel right
now you when you purchase a three month
babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free that's
six months for the price of three just
go to babel.com and use the promo code
h3tv that's b-a-b-b-e-l.com
code h3tv it's babel language for life
[Music]
did we use babel we
did didn't you try in one of the
language dan
i use it for some spanish yeah how was
that
uh
it's good yeah i'm not fluent yet
i i did like it but i was really hoping
you weren't asking me to say something
in spanish right now because it'd be
embarrassing say library
bibliotheca the guy is fluent thanks to
the bibliotheque did you hear the
pronunciation on that biblioteca
for some reason that's the one word
everybody remembers because it's really
fun to say yeah bibliotheka
anyway all thanks to babble
honey finally thank you honey we love
honey if you want to save free money
that's it we all shop online we've all
seen that promo code that taunts us at
the checkout but thanks to honey manual
searching for coupons online is a thing
of the past honey is the free shopping
tool that scours the internet for promo
codes and applies the best one it finds
to your cart honey supports over 30 000
stores online ranging from tech
gaming products
gaming products to popular fashion
brands and even food delivery come on
get the [ __ ] out of here
pissed about how good this product is
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites then the checkout honey
drops the drop down comes and all you
have to do is click the coupon apply
button wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons it can find for
that site and bada bing bada boom once
it finds a coupon you watch the price
drop magically i use honey all the time
it's literally insane you install it
it's a browser extension you install in
two clicks it's free and then whenever
you're shopping it's running
seamlessly in the background when you're
at checkout it goes oh by the way
there's a coupon here that's gonna save
you 50 [ __ ] dollars yes i regularly
we just showed the lev the levi's
100 bucks dude it was a 200 purchase and
it saved me a hundred bucks i wouldn't
have saved otherwise
here's the deal here's the proof in the
pudding
honey has saved its 17 million members
over two billion dollars bro if you
don't already have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
it's literally free and installs in a
few seconds and by getting it you'll be
doing yourself a solid and supporting
the show
love you honey for that
i never recommend something i don't use
so get honey for free at jointhoney.com
h3tv that's
jointhoney.comtv thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you
i love you sponsors i love my sponsors
[Music]
all right thank you zach
[Laughter]
oh man i saw this over the weekend
oh this is such a [ __ ] up that so this
is uh a giant wind turbine
blade yep
on the back of a semi truck i guess it's
a tough turn i get that right
yeah something went terribly wrong
though here in this whole situation yeah
clearly
because you can see the crossing starts
to go down train just came down on the
blade
dude i think that dude needs to start
flooring it at this point like he he's
taking his time a little bit
oh my god
you know like florida bro lauren
oh my god
[Music]
yeah this just happened on the weekend
dude this is like uh
this is a you know current event
and those that blade don't look cheap
those cannot be easy to make that was a
legendary [ __ ] up
but like he had so much time it's like
okay drive you're gonna get a dent on
the blade
you know what i mean
let's move it let's shake let's rattle
those dags oh you're saying they should
have just gunned it yes and not given a
[ __ ] about knocking over a sign or
something yeah probably gun it does seem
like a train's about to hit you yeah
that's a good point
like i mean they do seem to try at the
very end here
they're like okay go he almost clears it
he almost yeah that should have just
been happening immediately oh
my god wow
wow this is the first time for me in a
train accident
jesus yeah that was wild
don't [ __ ] with trans people in the
marvel universe
that's not edited
that's what it sounds that's what it
sounds like
it might have been edited on their end
but on our end now oh yeah it was
definitely on there and no we didn't we
did not
all right we got into what we got what
do we got lined up i can't see it dan so
i can't really well uh we got somebody
whose grandfather was a truck driver for
kiss and wouldn't want to be buried in
that coffin
interesting uh i've got somebody who's a
funny story about their grandparents
listen to the kiska i want to hear that
you want dr kiss guy
all right this is anthony just for you
zach anthony
uh is being brought in one second
anthony
anthony are you there
hello
okay anthony so so first of all
tell me about your your grandfather's
experience with kiss before we get to
the
the
coffin yeah yeah no so um my grandfather
was a truck driver he drove like the uh
equipment and sound stuff you know
speakers drum sets
the concert set it up for him yep
pretty much got to go all over the
country and uh i can say with like 100
confidence that
that coffin is not not the move
he would not be interested okay why
what's wrong with the kiss coffin
well i'm just saying that seems like
definitely more of like
a fan route like a super fan route than
someone who has an actual like
connection with the band you know it's
like they already have that
why would they need the coffin to
validate it okay so so your grandfather
is secure in his uh connection with the
band he doesn't need he doesn't need the
coffin anthony can i ask what era of
chaos what year was your grandfather uh
it would have been in the late 80s so
like air car era
uh yeah like like big time like he was
well he was driving for a lot of bands
though so it was like iron maiden uh he
went with bob seger
that's cool well do me a favor you're
you're speaking for your grandpa but
like let's be honest you got to ask the
guy
okay yeah you're right you're right
you got to ask him you're putting words
in his mind i didn't quite have the time
i didn't quite have the time all right
well
well get get get a hold of your grandpa
show him the coffin and i actually want
his real
i want to know what he thinks yeah
that's a good point oh absolutely
so are you able to call your grandpa now
or no
uh i'm not sure if i'd be able to get
him in on the call
all right well you can write us an email
i want to i want to know his genuine
reaction maybe film him
i'll give you his response yeah i just
don't want to put him on the spot like
no sure of course that's fair that's
fair but let's let's let's see let's let
your grandpa speak for himself i'm very
curious
yeah all right thank you for the call
thanks anthony yeah
have a good one yep
you know i mean who knows maybe yeah he
was kind of out of line to just speak
out totally
[Laughter]
i was gonna ask him if he would honestly
be buried in that
for the meme yeah no no no no no would
you honestly be buried in that coffin
like when i'm old and gray when you're
[ __ ] dead would you allow them to put
your body in that coffin and bury you
for eternity yes
i don't believe you i don't believe you
either you don't have to believe me
i don't believe you catch a vibe my
dudes
all right here we go we're going to be
buried in a ccr uh john fogarty cool
have fun in hell
what if we did a switcheroo and put you
in a ccr coffin well i guess i really
wouldn't know but all right i mean
we torture your poor soul forever
so i gotta say with with
what the preview was there for anthony i
thought that was going to go a different
direction that his grandfather told him
that kiss or giant [ __ ] that's what i
was which they are yeah absolutely
because they kind of have that
repetition well at least keane simmons
does i don't know if they're arrested
money hungry piece of [ __ ]
sucks yeah all right calm down
what are you trying to stand up for gene
i don't know
i'm already being sued i don't need any
more i need gene humans out for my ass
that's defamation hi i'm vince
what the [ __ ] you saying i am vince he
was born in israel
oh hi oh hi
oh
all right so who so who's who's coming
out with the cheeseburgers
whose album cover is this
wait did we add yours because i would
guess yours right ian well so ethan sent
me one emoji i didn't understand the the
he didn't get the assignment did the
assignment
well maybe you should if you told me
about it i would have understood it
you have to send your most uh oh here's
what's in my what's in my frequently
used okay okay okay
all right here i'll do that right now
but there's a lot of so so the one with
the hamburger is not ethan as well
nothing oh so set uh send that to cam
actually because then he could make
okay make the cover
this one i feel like is not gonna rep i
don't know why these are my most recent
but
yeah it's some strange ones showed up
for me as well i do want a burger now
that i see it though to be honest y'all
got yo dan flash's donate five dollars
said who's getting buried in a teddy
fresh coffin let me tell you ethan is
for sure he's like i would well oh yeah
forever
death baby have you ever seen him not
wearing teddy brush yeah i get buried in
a h3 podcast coffin everyone's face is
around it
would you want me my face on your coffin
just staring at you
what if my face like was a 3d engraving
on the bottom of the lid so it's us face
to face beautiful all right abe real
real question like all jokes aside would
you get an h3 tattoo
if it was like really little and it said
like
h3 podcast yeah but it's not that crazy
of a request for him i mean he's got a
lot of tactics i'm just curious but i
don't have anything in the next week's
segment there you go i was about to say
content baby we're getting we're going
to get we're going to make av get an h3
that looks like a swazi on his forehead
ab manson
where did that come from because i
didn't want to say swat about swazi you
never heard swazi no
okay i'm a trendsetter you know a lot of
people in saying we've been we've been
too mean to av so i just want to say
[ __ ] said that
i saw some people
but i will say i want to say this then
in all seriousness
[Music]
a b
is
such a valued member of this crew he
works hard he works late his dedication
cannot be questioned he's an asset to
the show and i'm thankful
every week that he's here it was one of
the best decisions i ever made bringing
ab and lena out and what can i say i
love the guy he's an asset he's a great
guy
huge he's got great character
[Music]
save children from burning cars on the
reg
allegedly
[Music]
not gonna go are you crying
[Music]
it's freaking
yeah i actually just want to say that
for real well thank you so much and i
and i do say one of the reasons everyone
talks [ __ ] i feel like with me is
because i talk [ __ ] a lot that's why too
so it may seem different for you guys
but i'm always going back and forth as
well i think there i think there some
people said there's like a hazing
process because technically you are like
still the newest kind of
like you've been here a year right
and i feel like
adding someone to the crew is always
hard to work them into the dynamic it
does take time it really does
but you know after a year i do feel like
we've we've worked you in pretty good
now i feel like you're integrated but
there's still a little bit of hazing i
think that happens
okay
you know i think if anything it's just a
little bit of hazing
it's all good it's full of trolling we
do a little trolling a little bit of
truth i i do gotta say this man i love
this man like all jokes aside i do love
him he's one of my best friends and i
even uh darris i call him my brother so
uh zach does love it i call my husband
no this is what up you zach
my one year yeah when i noticed is my
one year
uh
it got me thinking when i first started
and zach really like really helped me
with it it's not easy switching from
being a nobody to being on such a
popular show and zach was really there
for me and all the guys have been there
yeah you went from a nobody to a cameo
superstar cameo superstar baby
that's a huge life uh change mm-hmm
god bless appreciate it i just want to
say that uh genuine uh words of uh
care and love
oh yeah let's not for best moving on uh
moving on from maybe thank you thank you
that suck your dick also
i got [ __ ] to do
yeah i mean speaking of al roker and
i've watched this clip before but this
is truly
a magnificent
one of the best clips on the internet
that to this day confuses
and mystifies mk ultra
this is some egg this is some mk ultra
[ __ ] this is definitely someone said
that
here's al roker
with disgraced matt lauer of with the r
word button matt lauer such a freak
so awesome like
just what a freak he is it came out
yeah
i mean awesome in that
it instilled awe in you at just how
absurd the situation was yeah
anyway here's al roker having a glitch
bro
um
yeah here alongside matt lauer
just watch al roker's face
[Music]
memories he got triggered that was the
word history the holy ghost was the word
today elvis presley passed away the king
of rock the holy ghost
sent him
spy ruling
waiting for the king down in the jungle
i can make such a good edit from that i
want to edit something can we zoom in on
his face
a certain amount of distance did she say
something provocative
yes like they say in catholic school
leave room for the holy ghost that set
him off dude but did she say something
provocative or no she said
like they say in no matter what the
contact was talking about
when they no because they were
pretending to dance and they danced
really far away from each other and they
were saying encounters no it wasn't that
it was nothing
dude maybe maybe something happened in
the catholic school that like just some
deep-seated trauma came up
there it's a lot of
memories today actually it's a big day
in music history and somebody explained
to me
today
a long time ago
and had a whole discussion about it
the conclusion that we came to is that
he has
an in-ear
and
somebody's a producer is talking to him
unacceptable and so he's like kind of
distracted and just
i don't buy that one second the man's a
professional he knows how to deal with a
producer in his ear yeah no no i mean
the more like it's it's mk ultra goes
deeper yeah deeper
he was clearly given the kill commands
to kill matt lauer anyway
and he's having an eternal battle he
loves history he loves matlab years ago
today elvis presley he loves matt
but he's been ordered to kill him
he's fighting right now he's fighting
the demon
who will win him
he wins
[Music]
i left that music
all right so here we go should i am i
waiting now for cam to add me
oh uh let me see if he's done
what else we got we got any we got any
suggestions we got any what do you guys
want to hear me talk about what do you
want me to hear me react to you got
questions what do we got
bring it to me baby uh do you want to
take another person who's got a guest
for the co-host
sure all right
tanya
miss tanya
are you there tanya hi tanya from idaho
has a guest for the co-host okay tanya
you've got one guess
one guess oh my god okay
uh bobby lee
is it bobby lee it is not bobby lee i
love bobby lee though but it's not
probably
you can ask for one clue you get one
clue
okay is it
green
is it green
do you want to unpack that question a
little bit for me
is the okay does the person wear a
costume that happens to be green oh oh i
see where we're going i see where we're
going with that it is not gekko it is
not the gekko as much as we can
did enjoy that do you enjoy that episode
i had a lot of fun doing that i love the
gecko but it is not the get-go yeah all
right thank you i feel like it's a
really good
balance but
like you and the get-go make really good
content but thank you for taking the
gecko buddy you got it tanya thank you
thank you tanya
i think we gotta
love i think we gotta rethink the whole
show now based off of that suggestion
let's go back to the drawing board
i'm surprised nobody's guessing
it i mean there's a lot of people in the
world i guess it's i mean i guess a lot
of people i mean in terms of oliver and
bobby i guess you know those are both
good guesses you think we should stop
they're going to get close abc thinking
we should abort what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
what somebody said please donkey
oh my god i don't i don't think so
we do love donkey though
sorry guys i had to go uh potty real
fast
all right i've got my my calls queued up
here
bernie madoff story
damn
all right brianna has a guest let's talk
to brianna
all right brianna what's your guess hi
exactly lianna brian wait what did i say
wrong
it's leona oh leona lyanna
hi
lyanna how are you guys good how are you
i'm good
what's your guess awesome well i have
like one like wishful guest that is not
like a real guest and then i have a real
guest
okay let's start wishful
okay well i think miss kip would be
great even hassan we would love that
i mean actually well miss kim was in
austin so i don't think you can make
that work but
miss gif does not have enough
subscribers to uh
he doesn't have a big accident active
enough audience to warrant even sitting
next to me in the studio yeah we regret
ever having him on really yeah he's real
yeah he's just a small time
just kidding obviously i also like don't
once you be right that's the i don't
want to be right because i don't want
dan to be upset
but this is my real guess because you
have to like level out the playing field
after what you know happened with keem
and everything so i'm thinking it's jack
filled
it's not jack's face
damn
i'm not a bad guess though not a bad
guess not a bad guess
thank you amy thank you liana thank you
thank you with peace and love thank you
so much we're pretty much running the
gauntlet of every possible
person
okay we've got liv 23 needs dating
advice i love giving dating advice
for some reason hello hi liv what can i
do
hi for you
um i don't really know if you can do
anything personally
um
but i would like to know
just in your experience
i mean obviously you got very lucky oh
yeah there's no doubt about that
so what do you do if if you're not lucky
so what what should i do because i have
not been lucky
nor successful but when i when i put
down all of my traits on a piece of
paper there's really nothing wrong with
me okay well liv first of all
i see you're 23. so let's you know let's
lower our expectations a little bit i
mean i didn't meet ella till i was like
20 you know in my mid-20s okay
late 20s or well
that's almost mid-20s yeah you're
getting okay so you're worried okay so
so how many what was your last
relationship
when was it yeah it ended about a year
ago
okay
and have you been on a date in that year
can you turn it down a little bit i've
been on many dates
and how do you meet these guys
um
a couple of them were from work but the
other ones were from a dating app but
not
i don't know if i'm allowed to like like
name drop on here we don't really want
to advertise i don't think for these
dating apps but it wasn't are you trying
to are you trying to promote your dating
profile
i i could like you guys should have like
a bachelor bachelorette thing because i
need some help
but anyways okay so do you think that
let me ask you like tim poole he would
say
it's not the problem isn't with me the
problems with the world do you feel that
that do you identify with the temple
kind of thing or do you think that
there's maybe something that you can
work on personally
i'm not like a narcissist but i know
that i'm like an awesome person
so tell me about very listen
i like video games
we love that
already like yeah i think i feel like
guys like that
whatever okay let's not lean on that too
much go ahead
you're creative i'm creative yeah i'm
very apathetic
like shane dawson
uh
i do not want to be
so you play video games you're
empathetic
you're creative
what do you do for work
for work i'm a grad student right now
but i'm also a poet and i want to be a
high school teacher
okay that's an awesome job vin diesel's
interested or would you like to would
you are you would you ever dave vindys
yeah vin diesel finds you attractive
yeah i've seen the pacifier that movie
is pretty good
so tell me what what's going wrong i
feel i feel like you're not giving me
enough information you're saying
i want to get lucky i'm awesome you're
not giving me enough information what
kind of guys are you looking are you
shooting too high like sometimes i find
a lot of people
and i mean uh maybe sometimes they aim
too high they're looking for people out
of their league do you feel like uh like
like when you're looking at guys like on
a scale of one to ten you know 10 being
like brad pitt in his prime like hot hot
[ __ ] like let's go you know what i'm
saying like the sight of him makes you
ovulate kind of thing so
what number are we looking for
well i wouldn't i'm going to have to
stop you right there i i would not put
brad pitt as my 10
all right well you get the idea yeah i'm
just trying i'm just trying to set the
scale up for you so what which number
are we looking at
we're looking at for me i'm gonna say
like six you're looking for a good six
that's not high i mean that's reasonable
that's unreasonable yeah that's all you
need in life is a good six
and how would you
yeah take it from a six i i would say i
was a six on my bet in my best condition
so i feel like guys with six can do a
lot you can do the everything six is
everything ethan you're you're an eight
nine four i'm not an aids
zach thank you but you're very charming
you're handsome you're you're everything
zack i love you
you're more flattering than my own
mother
so okay so
where would you place yourself on a
scale of one to ten
um if you would have asked me like a
couple years ago i think i would say
like seven
but now honestly i think i'm a nine i've
gained a lot of confidence and i've
looked at all the good things about
myself and i'm just like frustrated that
other people don't see it do you know
what i
mean um
i'm thinking there might be a disconnect
here yeah i mean nine is pretty high and
i don't celebrate a self-rated nine too
self-rated nine is very very high uh liv
i have to i have to warn you
i
i mean you can only if you if you know
if you met me
if you looked at my dating profile it's
very charming it would you would
definitely
be you know if you weren't i i i hadn't
already met
the goddess walking among us
you you know who you're giving me vibes
of
and you're i don't think you're gonna
like this but
from and sam if you list the goddess
from the bachelor you
she used to be the queen but then she
turned into the goddess on bachelor in
paradise
i do watch that show oh god
i did so you know who i'm talking about
okay so you've given me goddess vibes i
don't it doesn't sound good
[Music]
well i think i think
okay let me let me let me try to get
into more detail because i feel like
we're not we're just stuck on the
surface when you go on a date with a guy
in general you say you go on a lot of
dates so what are the reasons usually
why these relationships don't progress
um i guess because i see a lot of red
flags and then i just kind of talk
myself out of it okay
so it's either that half the time or the
other half
they're not interested
okay let's start with the red flags what
kind of red flags do you see
yeah
basically
just if they don't like want to know
about me i guess if they don't if
they're not very good listeners that's
like a big thing i'm looking for it's
fair enough for people to just
and also be like oh my god like ask me
questions like what's your
i don't know whatever questions people
ask um
[Music]
i mean i think that's fair enough i
think a lot of guys don't listen enough
you know but you could but like if
you're talking about like first second
date you know a lot of people get
nervous and they
just talk about themselves because they
i don't want to fill up the space yeah
they're trying to fill up the space
they're trying to sell themselves i
don't know
yeah okay so when you're saying guys
aren't interested in you why do you
think that is
i i think it's because i'm this is what
i've deducted but i
they might say otherwise um i feel like
i'm just too like
outgoing and like open right at first
like i tell them like whatever
i'm
thinking
without being like you know i don't say
like rude things i'm just a very like
open outgoing kind of person
and maybe that's a turn off to people
i don't think so i think that
alone isn't a bad thing
there's something happening here we're
not getting to
right dan yeah there's something going
on here liv i'm unable to put my finger
on it as i don't think i've bamboozled
you
no no no i think you're being totally
honest
no no no no i think you're being totally
honest i'm just trying to figure out
what is going on here
you're asking me for advice
and i'm trying to yeah
i'm trying to give it to you i'm just
trying to tell you what
yeah i'm as confused as you are
which is why i need help
but you might want to i'm
how many dates do you go on a month
right now like one
like one
is that enough for you or do you think
it should be more
i think it should be more i just don't
know how to like actually start like a
deep conversation with people because
like dating apps it's all like the small
talk and i'm like i don't like it's so
annoying to kind of like get
into
like deeper conversations with people
yeah like no amount of deeper
yeah i don't know i never did the dating
app so it's hard for me to but i i can
imagine how how difficult and
frustrating that can be you know did any
of you guys meet significant others on
dating apps yeah i did oh you did yeah
oh fantastic no am i my kind of general
advice with with tinder or bumble or any
of those is
because this is extremely common thing
with you know it being awkward during
that initial chat or whatever if you
match with somebody and you're
interested with them
you got to get past the chatting on the
app
quickly like so awkward meet up for
coffee or something or move on like
immediately well yeah you know what i
mean you're in a better position to give
advice because dan is in a really
loving relationship and they're living
together they're doing great and i
didn't know you guys met on the app but
we sure did
yeah i think what do you think about
dan's advice just get out there and meet
people and give them a shot what do you
think about that liv
yeah that's that's kind of what i do and
then i get discouraged for like a couple
weeks and then i just kind of tried
again but i guess it's a like a cycle
let me ask you this
how many matches do you get a month
because you go on one date a month if
you're a nine as i understand it on
dating apps you should be
unindated
with
inundated inundated you should be
absolutely bombarded with [ __ ]
i had a feeling
i i am and you know what it's unwanted
most time
but how is it you only have one match
was it okay so you have lots of matches
you only you just go on one date
yeah because it takes a lot to actually
like make me
like
want to go out and like meet this person
like there has to be like some kind of
connection already there i think you
like that's my fault i think yeah i
think that's it yeah i don't know you
may have skipped over prince charming
you know that maybe because
how
how difficult is it to
to make a connection with somebody over
an awkward text message conversation on
a dating app unless you know what i mean
like you know and liv let's be honest
the guys with the slick opening lines
who are charming in text messages aren't
going to be necessarily the guys that
are boyfriend material you know
i see i see through that [ __ ] like they
need to be like maybe you don't clearly
you don't if they fall
then no like if if they're holding a
fish in their profile that's a red flag
they're holding a fish okay well
this isn't my first maybe you should try
going with a guy with a fish he might
surprise you maybe
am i allowed to uh plug my instagram if
there's anybody who wants to dm me no oh
my god no that is desperate
[Laughter]
now are you looking for someone in the
foot foot soldier army i thought
i you know what there's a lot of nice
soldiers why do you want why do you want
unsolicited dms from people watching
this versus
tinder i don't get that
like
i don't know i guess i guess you got i
guess you got me i think you got to
chill i mean you you're coming across as
a little desperate i think even
self-admitted uh you know i think you
even used that word at one point um so
with with peace and love no i i didn't
you know okay well you're coming across
that okay can we
can we review in private like send it to
the guys and maybe i can look at your
instagram profile i'm i just i don't
want to blast it out to everyone at this
moment it's just a little
it's a little sketchy for you so i don't
want to i don't want to
put you out to the hordes
but what i will do if you're okay with
it is that if you send it to one of the
guys we can review your profile and tell
you what we think is that okay
what's the best way i guess a b
do you follow a b on instagram
and send him a dm right now and he'll
check out your profile and then we can
give some tips is that okay with you liv
i don't wanna do anything you're not
comfortable with
no that's fine
okay
my algorithms get crushed
she's not desperate to get it out there
i i didn't say that dan how dare you
she's not desperate
she's not desperate
you can cut the dan's face again
yeah okay i can't see dana is she i
don't i wouldn't i don't think you're
desperate i just think
well you're impatient i can't say that
i guess maybe that's a better word for
it impatient yeah yeah
yeah all right so send that to uh a b
okay
and then in the meantime just hold i'm
gonna keep you on the line i'm gonna
review some uh
some memes stay just hang out yeah i'm
gonna i'll put you back on hold and when
i'm home we're ready we'll bring you
back in yeah thank you liv we're gonna
get to the bottom of this okay i'm gonna
help you out
we're gonna figure we're gonna figure
out what's going on all right
all right i just returned her to the
queue it's an interesting issue you know
i think a lot of guys would like oh it's
hard for you i can't even get a [ __ ]
match like i understand it's tough being
a dude out there on the apps
but i'm gonna figure it out i'm gonna
get to the bottom of this okay
a self-rated nine does is a red flag
because a nine is like
damn near perfection nine is everything
nine is astronomical
yeah i mean a nine is like you don't
mean many nines in your life
five percent means everything a 10 is
like uh
one person out of a billion
let's face it most humans are ugly
i would say 90 of humans are ugly
you know still haven't gotten a message
yet all right she'll figure it out
all right but in the meantime i was
actually wanting to watch
these uh tyler tyler woodley's
tyler woodley i freaking did i forget
his name tyrone woodley okay
knowledge so we got there's actually a
bunch of videos here i want to watch
okay so here's so they they agreed
here they agreed that the loser would
get a tattoo of i love
whatever their name is so here they
agreed to it if i beat you you have to
get i love jake paul tattooed on you
but but if you beat me i get i love
tyrone woodley tattooed on me and you
have to post it on your instagram feed
dealer no deal put
he actually shook on i don't know why he
did
what's your thing
bro
y'all think i should do it
oh this guy this guy has no [ __ ]
confidence
bad
deal or no deal yeah they they shook on
it
okay but then you know obviously it's
like i'm not doing that [ __ ]
and on twitter everyone's like no
[ __ ] way
so where's the post here it is thank you
guys
so tyron's like yo i won that fight i
demand a rematch and here here it is
so you don't want to fight me again
[Music]
you had your chance i was nothing but
respectful to you right now
you're the one that got wobble almost
sent through the rope if these [ __ ]
ropes wasn't seven foot two you would
have went through the ropes i landed the
power punches
you missed
if you if you get the tattoo not scared
running back if you if you if you get
the tattoo i love jake paul let's run it
back okay
let's go
make the bed
you had your opportunity so he says he's
gonna get it
and everyone's like dude if that
[ __ ] tattoos that tat towels
that
he can't put that on his body right
if you're bullying kids out there stop
it yeah
he can't put that on his body right
here he goes into more in depth actually
oh what the [ __ ] somebody that dude hd
on there though they sure did that's a
foot soldier literally that is a literal
foot soldier
petey davidson
and their profile picture is pete
davidson it might be the real pete
davidson yeah i think he's a fan and
well thank you for that uh
wow
dedication
here he is talking about the uh
the tattoo i haven't seen this so
really curious yeah one more question
mark tyler you never talk to tonight
i need to see some paperwork for this
rematch because um
i think that's i think that's a game
plan where are you going to go to are
you you gonna make sure that you get
something in paper before you get the
tattoo so that they have to do the
rematch to be honest he gave me his word
he hasn't [ __ ] he hasn't did me wrong
since
so i kind of gotta roll with him on that
um stop
it he's gonna get the tattoo for a
rematch
the [ __ ]
oh man how much money to get i love jake
paul tattooed on you zach would do it
for rolex probably
yeah
actually no no don't do that really jake
really is a piece of [ __ ] though
it's one of the first times he's ever
declined that yeah my hatred towards
them is uh strong
did you get it maybe
not yet i have about 200 messages right
now all saying hey i'm the girl oh no
wait we got to get her back on and find
out how do we how do we figure out her
real life she could tell me what her
profile starts with uh wait one of the
screeners can just ask her privately
here yeah
yeah i think i may have just found it
you'd how do you know it's her
well this is the first one whose names
actually live oh and she has pictures of
a profile
uh
yeah this this is her oh we got the
profile send me send me a discard i
won't put it on the screen let's all
review this and
i want to help her
out roker admits to [ __ ] his fans
let's [ __ ] go
we're on the al roker chain here boys
yeah this guy
this guy's done it all bypass and you
know your bowel has been reconstructed
you think you're pretty safe and i
probably went off
uh and eat something i wasn't supposed
to
and as i'm walking to the press room i
don't know i think i gotta you know pass
a little gas here so
why are you talking about this
only a little something extra came out
bro
i pooped my pants uh not horribly but
enough not horrible which is a common
side effect of this surgery exactly okay
and so
you know i
was panicking so i got to the restroom
in the press room throughout the
underwear you know and just commando and
what did that tell you it told me that
i've got to be very vigilant as to what
i eat
dude
bro this isn't the h3 podcast to be
sharing that kind of [ __ ]
oh olivia and sam think this is oh yeah
i think we all think that this is
probably a bad idea to tell you the
truth i wasn't gonna rate her i was just
gonna give her advice yeah i'm not
raiding her
well hold on let me send me that i just
want to look at it now i'm so curious
all right here we go
[Music]
yeah we should get a girl here why why
do we not have a girl we have two girls
here
because they're screening the calls
i'm not for the record i am not looking
to rate her that is not
what i'm doing i am just looking at like
how she lives her life
what's her what she's signaling to the
world you know what i mean this isn't
i'm not raiding her attractiveness that
is not
what i am doing
okay
but like she she's you know yeah she's
pretty she's normal looking
so like there's there's no red flags
here nothing oh she's wearing a teddy
fresh hoodie i love that
yeah there's nothing i don't see
anything wrong here
i'm not raiding her come on guys i'm
better than that
not raiding
[Music]
thank you you want to join us olivia we
got reinforcements yeah we need a woman
here before i get cancelled
yeah what do you think about this
situation you want to bring her back
sure
olivia talking your mind hello there you
go cool we good yeah we're good
okay
what am i doing wrong olivia
brutally honest with me all right here
we go
a group of men
yep judging a girl's profile
[Music]
broadcasted to a large number of people
yep
with an already established power
dynamic oh [ __ ] could be
a little problematic okay but wait i'm
not showing her profile right i'm not
rating her good that's the thing that i
was super because you were talking about
how she was saying that she was a nine
i'm talking more like a spirit like the
spiritual she okay you know but good i'm
glad you're here
i'm not talking about physical
attractiveness okay and i don't think
she is either because she says i used to
be seven but i'm not because i'm more
confident all right
i'm glad we clarified i'm also glad we
could we clarified
yeah
well i really don't know what to tell
her ultimately though
i think she just got to get out there
and keep meeting guys you know
do you have any advice for olivia
i would say
yeah just keep trying
don't be
scared
of someone you think you might not like
if you enjoy
what they have to say
say that again
like if you don't necessarily think that
they're super cute or they don't like
fit your mold yeah
if you enjoy talking to them thank you
so much for the music yeah um
i would say
go for it see what happens
go for it even if they're not your
perfect beauty that's a much better way
of putting it than what i said earlier
which was effectively the same thing
because i was getting the i was getting
the vibe that she gets lots of matches
but she was not giving most of them a
chance and that's what i was trying to
say you got to bring live on let's let's
get back out there go on some of these
dates i would love to talk to liz all
right let's come back and olivia thank
you you saved the day absolutely i would
never dream i would never dream of
raiding a girl we just wanted to make
sure no thank you thank you and guys
come on we respect women here you guys
know that absolutely
i was just wondering if i was just
wondering if she had a picture of her
with like a samurai sword
and like you know a wee confederate flag
that part of it is cool i was nervous
that we were going down a different road
no i know i know
okay liv we're not we're not raiding you
we're not going to blast you out i'm
sorry if it came off that way i just
wanted i'm just checking you're like
relative norm uh you know whatever i
don't know the [ __ ]
well the thing is i i think abe may have
pulled up the wrong profile because i
don't think i'm wearing a teddy fresh
hoodie oh
who is this uh-oh
in your instagram profile or in your
dating profile wait i take back
everything i said
do you have a picture yeah i definitely
i am on my instagram file i'm sorry this
one says tu grad student that's not you
yeah okay i'm so sorry i thought like
you were looking at the
the hinge profile and i was like i don't
think i have a uh oh so this is you
false alarm thank god this is you yeah
okay okay is that sister merch
okay so so so anyway we've got olivia
here and she has some advice for you so
let the ladies talk for a minute
hey what's up hello
how you doing
do you wait so do you want me to look at
your profile is that what's happening
no
okay yes yes i i feel comfortable
looking at it okay yeah you have how do
i how do i pull it up
maybe we'll show you right there well
that's her instagram baby oh let's look
at her dating profile yeah that's what
i'm trying to do yeah when you send a b
your hinge profile yeah like take
screenshots of it she did i got it oh i
want to see that i want to see that too
send it to me
yeah that's way better than instagram
okay
all right yeah and we can talk about the
answers to the questions and everything
perfect okay
there's a lot that i'm a little nervous
about but it's too late to change it now
well we're not gonna show it we're not
gonna show it oh yeah yeah we'll just
talk about it yeah
okay
while we're waiting
i ordered um a shirt from teddy fresh
and it's my first
like full price actual new item because
the other thing i got is from resale but
i'm very excited
which shirt did you get
the like the tattoo
oh hell yeah that one sold out fast
congrats
and thank you for your support
all right olivia you've got the hinge
profile do we think here
i think that
the photos you said are like tiny by the
way maybe
yeah i can't read what does that say
first round is on me
if you tell me your interpretation of
danny darko
or donnie darko
yeah yeah i love that movie but it's a
deep cut it is a deep cut
i'm in i mean very deep cut for somebody
if you want someone to get that and they
get that wait that's your cover question
bro i can't read this [ __ ] it's like the
signs of a damn my thumbnail i i didn't
screenshot i just saved
save images
you know what dude i think it's pretty
obvious you just gotta you gotta agree
you just gotta give people more chances
your profile's fine
i think you're you think that you're
like a very
you know
you are very dateable worthy person
clearly and i think you just gotta wait
23 you're pretty young man just you know
just keep getting out there and taking a
shot and i think olivia's advice is good
just like
you want to restate it for her
sure um i think
that
even if
the person that you match with or you're
reading their profile you don't
necessarily think that they are exactly
your physical type
who knows what could happen
if you meet in person and you have a
conversation
i don't know i think that that could be
pretty cool if you find something that
way
there you have it
all right
good luck to you okay
yes good luck keep trying thank you for
your advice
roasting and not roasting i appreciate
it all and zero rating we did not rate
you and i'm sorry
that we thought it was going that way
but it didn't go that way it was never
going to go that way
all right liv take care you're going to
be fine i prom you're you're good you're
great you're in good shape all right
you're going to be fine
thank you all right have a good day
everyone all right bye
yeah i mean she's 23 i wouldn't i know
people get like anxious about why don't
you stay we need you yeah we need you
desperately
i know people get anxious about dating
but at 23 that's that that's pretty
young i think you know
what
yeah you got plenty i mean you don't
even really start having kids these days
until you're in your early 30s you know
i went on a tinder date a few weeks ago
and zach got very mad at me for not
having the boy buy me pizza
say what sorry i was telling zach about
it and he was and he was like did you
make him buy you dinner and i thank you
make him
usually that's you know it's a respect
thing when you know
the respect thing
what do you think about that i disagreed
with him i wasn't hungry
but zach said that it's the principle of
the matter so no matter no matter your
hunger levels zach you're saying the man
buys the food food is everything food is
yeah
did he buy you anything
i i told him i wasn't hungry so he's not
hungry i was not hungry
but who knows maybe in the future he'll
buy me a pizza
do you guys still see each other
he is coming back into town tonight so
all right maybe pizza's on the maybe
pizza second chance for pizza maybe a
second chance for pizza
we should get pizza since i'm not vegan
anymore
let's get pizza
do you want me to order a pizza oh my
god let's wait let me think on it peach
is actually very nutritious
can somebody look into this this was in
the suggestion
thing talk about how on episode 33 of
the podcast with tai lopez
he talked about how he created the dark
triad test in 2017.
there's no such thing as a coincidence
either 45 minute mark or an hour 45.
somebody please pull up
that's episode all right all right all
right we're gonna there's no way that
tai lopez made the dark triad i learned
about the dark triad test in my theories
of personality class last year there's
no way there's no way but this isn't
saying that he created it this is saying
that he talked about how he created it
on our show no but tai lopez claimed he
created the dark triad that's what this
person's saying pull it up we got a
great question either at the 45 minute
mark or the hour 45 mark somebody's on
that
um i want to talk about
we have a lot of great video suggestions
here i want to go over
one oh here oh you found it love okay
this is trippy all right ty lopez
are they right on this test no i don't
judge you like block they judge
themselves one of the questions is i
feel like you have to be stupid to fail
that test
it's so that's the whole point do you
ever
well the craziest question that people
sometimes answer or strongly agree do
you enjoy picking on losers people will
be like yes yes you're an idiot if you
answer yes but there's a lot of people
there's a lot of books i'm sure there is
talking about the derby but i don't say
that
but there's stupid bullies out there so
basically you have to be stupid and
eating
that's the whole point do you want to
see people don't cut enough people off
knowledge
by the way i still don't believe him the
people answer i like picking on losers
you're in my garage who would answer yes
to that i mean that's psychotic is that
even a question on the test i've never
seen a question
i think what happened is tai lopez read
a cliff notes on it and
can you blame him when he reads like 14
books a day or whatever it is that he
says yeah
okay so is the emoji okay we got the
emoji everyone we're gonna guess whose
emojis these are
i don't know how accurate this is gonna
be but
we got monkeys burgers skull and
this is zach's the beers give it away
no
um
i would have guessed you
i don't especially with the money bag am
i right oh it's uh got em
okay
um today bees is it ian's is it dan i'm
not gonna guess because i think i know
whose it is because i think this person
sent me the beers
you can guess you're not excluded i mean
let's keep it wrong i'm guessing ian
uh yeah this one's mine you doing the
monkey see monkey don't hear emojis yeah
he does hit us hit the monkeys sometimes
what's with the use of the monkeys
oh
year is it i'll kind of do them like uh
well the burger emoji's there too so you
hit burgers a lot
sometimes but it'll kind of be like
what if what if we had burgers for
dinner
yeah it's the cheeky monkey all right
who's is this we've got
we've got a siren we've got a trophy the
butterfly emoji
fire love praying hands
uh
did olivia do one
day
i would guess so
maybe olivia or sam
the butterfly makes me feel that way
no
go ahead ian who is it this one is
ethan's this is me the butterfly
to the butterfly queen donarky
that should have been a good giveaway
yeah you dropped the trophy i love it
yeah yeah what is the trophy i've never
seen you use the truth but the prey
hands i use a lot yeah true
the trophy is weird that doesn't matter
never it was there i just all right
lipstick um
i have no bro what is this this
this is a b
yes i think that that is yes give away
what the [ __ ] is this bro
i don't know why i noticed that they put
the picture in there yeah what's with
the lipstick doug i was telling this i
was telling them this before the show i
had no idea where the lipstick came from
uh-huh i could easily made up an excuse
but i really don't i've never used it in
my life and what is this one the blue
guy with the
that's when i would make starkiller
videos with them emoji i would hide my
face oh okay yeah
so that's like a custom emoji yeah
so
next up we've got obviously this is sam
yeah this is sam for sure yeah no that
was yeah immediately honestly and then
up next we got ooh brains
trains
and butterflies
cool what the hell is this cam
no i would say this is someone who hates
apple yeah absolutely this is a samsung
oh
these are yes this this is mine this is
man those are some green text emojis
what do you use the train for
hype train maybe squirt gun
oh this is another android user well
this one's pretty obvious
i don't know who use
look look again
oh love yeah swedish flag
do you send people the swedish flag that
seems a little
yeah
the american flag for life
never well we're big patriots here in
sweden so i've got to represent
oh the queen the queen
uh oh this is sam or this is a no this
is olivia i got this emoji from you
has got to be yours is that me is that
mine yes this is your oh that's mine
yeah
i do love that this one is actually good
you sent this to me the other night and
i was like that's a good emoji it's just
like so fun
it's like what does it mean like that
you just transcended it's like no no
it's like ooh i'm getting a little head
massage you know what i mean
like if you say something like
i'm having so much fun tonight
it like adds a little bit of a like a
lightness to it
and is the rose an homage to the
bachelor
i don't know i started using that when i
was in like high school and i just never
stopped all right apparently we have
charles manson in our
crew because we have a tombstone a knife
a snake
and a pile of [ __ ]
what's that i mean zack's the only one
left zach what is wrong with you
i think it's not so much charles manson
more joker brand than anything but um
yeah
when did you use the tombstone
uh that was recent uh
[ __ ] i'm trying to remember
i forget which one did you ask about the
tombstone
oh he said
give me a kiss coffin and send no no no
no
[ __ ] what is that from
all right thank you
something happen yeah
somebody just said something about this
in the chat and i went and looked oh my
god gabe new club or white club game
monday hurts bro
i think he he was really invested in the
woodley fight
and he was super bummed oh that was he's
like [ __ ] what they how the [ __ ] did you
lose the jake ball [ __ ] baby
oh no i got so drunk watching the
[Laughter]
dude i love him
i'm so jealous of his life so drunk
i can't even remember the last time i
got drunk man i mean
it's time to party
[ __ ] baby no
my mom
all right let's talk about
if you guys have any suggested videos
let me know
but um i'm gonna move on and talk about
addison ray
yeah you start on that i'll queue some
stuff up yeah
so addison ray
came out i was so cap i put this thing
on immediately you know she came out
with this movie he's all that which is
a spin
on
she's all that from the 90s
mega hit teen hit
you know that movie kind of
like had a super low rating anyway
she's all that but it was like freddy
prince jr
and uh
i don't know it's just a racial it's
like a classic rachel lee cook yeah it's
a teenage classic
oh she's in this neighborhood all
walkers in this movie what the [ __ ]
oh wow rip to the goat my dude and
freaking uh
shaggy
matthew lillard
the little dog lillard's in it right i
mean yeah it didn't get great reviews
but it was a classic let's be honest
yeah this girl who's like gorgeous shows
up to school and we all pretend like
she's like a nerd that nobody wants
because she's wearing glasses right yeah
she's wearing my face and then he's like
i'm gonna make her the hottest girl in
school
as if she wasn't already beautiful i had
such a crush on her as a kid
she played addison's ray as in rey's mom
yeah this one i thought that was cool
that was pretty cool it was written by
the same person
wait so fred is in the original and
shaggy's in the new one oh wait no no
they're both in the original yeah i
didn't even think about the fact that
freddie prince jr is fred wait freddy
prince junior's in the new one
no no we're talking about scooby-doo
wait why the [ __ ] are we talking about
scooby because it's way more interesting
than she's all that guys
jackie is in the new one he plays the
principal
god the lillard then the new wilds and
the new ones so shaggy's in the new one
fred's in the old one fred's in the old
one yeah guys are we talking about
scooby doo still or what okay so then
it's a twist on that one
where addison raised the popular girl
and she's like i'm gonna make this guy
the most popular dude in school
4.5 pretty brutal actually it was so bad
you guys
i saw on my netflix homepage and i was
like i gotta see this [ __ ]
and uh here's the trailer
and action
we're live here in surprise we're on the
set of my boyfriend's brain yeah and
then this guy's supposed to be like 16.
sorry really well they're in high school
but there there's a lot of that classic
kind of like 30 year olds playing 16
year old right
the whole first of all the movie starts
where
she gets cancelled
because uh
she walks into her boyfriend's trailer
and finds him cheating on her
and she's living it on instagram
and she got cancelled
because she was upset and you could see
a snot bubble on her nose
and i was like this is so [ __ ] real
yeah and they were everyone started
calling her bubble girl because she was
mad i had a snot bubble because she was
crying
she got canceled she lost all of her
social followers because of that
so right out the gate
wow coming pretty bad pretty hot pretty
heavy good video
jordan
what are you doing okay let's not freak
out i honestly do recommend watching it
though like it's it is actually so bad
it's good
they did achieve that i feel like that's
what olivia was saying she said she
watched it twice yeah i i actually do
recommend it hard i was humiliated yeah
if you're pulling kids out there
anyway stupid and the guy
what do you think about the guy he's in
cobra kai and i thought he was pretty
good in that and he did
i feel like with what addison gave him
he did
pretty fine yeah but did you guys see
how hot he looked
yeah i did see that
that's kind of the whole point dan
it's quite the transformation
[Laughter]
yeah it has a 33 of rotten tomatoes
addison said give me a chance to show
myself as an actress which is kind of
funny
washington post said he's all that is
not all that not even a little bit of
that whoa
they [ __ ] got burned to the ground
dude
this tick tocker put together all the ad
placements i didn't notice this i guess
i was not paying close attention
but they outdid even adam sandler on the
product placement evidently i mean this
is pretty amazing addison ray's new
movie on netflix and she did a pretty
good job but the best part about it was
the product placement i mean we had the
privilege of seeing pizza hut kfc bounty
paper towels old navy smart food white
cheddar popcorn core hydration water
lucky charms cheerios adt home security
alarms eos skin care products mountain
dew soda mug root beer and pepsi
same shot sash tea bags sun chips lays
fritos doritos go smile pro luxury
toothpaste seinheiser microphones nissan
leaf aloe yoga's head to toe low oil
animal house vintage clothing cordo's
bakery bonus gatorade and cheetos lila
beauty cream blush mr clean spray maytag
microwave ovens spiritual gangster
clothing and tick tock i just watched
addison ray's new movie on netflix and
she did a pretty good
i guess that's what you get these days
from these kind of movies although it
really adds to the corniness of it to be
totally honest
like when there's just product placement
in every scene you get it this is a [ __ ]
yeah
i mean it's like an influencer movie so
i guess it's no surprise
this was another one that uh was making
its round on tick tock it was pretty
funny
i got you addison ray
okay so she's passing out flyers
she doesn't pass them out here
girl what are you grabbing
okay so she's passing out flyers
she doesn't pass him out here
girl what are you grabbing
got him
i gotta think i gotta think this movie
is actually probably pretty successful
because everybody's talking about it and
everyone seems to be enjoying watching
it for one reason or another right is
this the one they shut down
or they shut down the kovid yeah they
should shut down the badge or the
testing production
they shut down kova testing for this
[ __ ] bro
yeah use union station right yeah read
that again
read that headline man that was my good
god
yeah there's a big scandal in la where
they had like a big cova testing site
and they just shut that [ __ ] it was
literally the only one that was
accessible by public transportation in
the whole area awesome so it was like
yeah
yeah not good
here it is cover 19 test site closed
uh
she's all that remake
oh yeah they ended up overriding it like
the mayor stepped in
right or something everyone was bitching
about it yeah
brutal
are you playing this and this is like
the height of it everyone's like how is
this even possible
so stupid
for this for this for this [ __ ] movie
uh yeah uh um
uh what's her name kourtney kardashian
had a cameo and i have to say
straight up the worst acting i've ever
seen in a movie
and the best part of that movie
just when her on the bike right it's so
no she was she made a few cameos oh so i
only watched 30 minutes is the best part
just i was so funny two times she was
the best
i mean she's such a bad actress you'd
think that that after being on reality
tv for so long
it should be a little better
[Applause]
jessica hi what's up you're going viral
you're going viral wait that's another
ad that's a peloton
oh there you go
unfortunate my ex-husband's hiking
accident was unfortunate and he was
mauled by bears oh my god
oh my god this is really from the movie
yeah it's the worst acting
addison actually wasn't bad i think
i mean compared to courtney she's a
[ __ ] she's an academy award winner
a lot of people i know
to be fair to addison the writing was
also kind of crazy it's not much to work
with
look we pay you because you're the
makeover girl people buy products that
you recommend and i'm still that girl no
you're a meme you're a bubble girl
you're a bubble girl it's
so wait you're
pulling my sponsorship that's really
problematic for my college listen people
want pageant head to toe
i know i've lost a lot of followers but
i can get them back i just
need a chance to redeem myself that's
all sweetie i am your biggest supporter
no one has more faith in you than i do
but until you turn things around don't
talk to me love ya
is that the worst acting and anything
ever
i mean i commit it
that's a razzy worthy
i think this movie's gonna sweep the
razzies this year
probably i just looked over at the chat
and i said am i crazy does courtney look
like a deep fake
right right hurt
with peace and love
what is this existence looks like a deep
fake at this point every matthew what
would you say
really wasn't worth that reaction
actually
wait what did you say i said her whole
existence she looks like a deep face
the whole family's a deep thing right
yeah
not like the loudest groan i've ever
heard from zach though like that was
like beyond the pale
and he's all that okay wow interesting
now we're talking okay this has 700
views so so i'm trusting you guys this
is principal announcing oh this is the
new one
under the seat which really doesn't
matter he was in speaking he's involved
is what we were trying to convey her to
earthquakes coming up so don't forget to
vote online for your prom king and queen
a tremendous honor they'll always
remember unless they throw up in their
date shoe in the limo and remember that
instead
just kidding
we have jordan
yeah this [ __ ] is so dumb what the [ __ ]
is this a joke
okay i am told that cameroon is an
actual student if you put your tick
tocks down you have a chance to see some
people dancing in real life we have some
weird ass traditions at this school
you're the dj great um where's your
stuff my stuff yeah your equipment your
your
for your phone yeah kinda
boomer alert
lillard the goat willard dude the will
shag dude shot the freaking shagadelic
all right so let's move it on i got some
good stuff here oh let's see if we have
any questions
um
yeah co-host guess
oh she's the baby that a b saved and now
keemstar won't let her alone
that's a call-in yeah what's i mean
jessica 27 claims she's a baby
hi ethan how are you hi jessica is this
the baby that a b saved
yes it is it's so great to finally talk
with you guys yeah so was he telling the
truth or or was it exaggerated
no abe was 100 telling the truth oh um
he literally saved my life
oh that's that's so nice to hear that
confirmation uh from the baby i really
didn't believe it until this moment baby
thank you thank you yeah
i appreciate it so yeah but on the flip
side keemstar won't leave me alone now
yeah
oh wait what do you mean by that
um so you know keemstar is clearly like
h3's biggest fan i think yeah um so when
i when abe told the story about how
he saved my life i got a dm from
keemstar
and um his first response was just going
google gaga and i was like come on dude
like he was google gaga
i feel like yeah
oh brother yeah and then um
he sent me a video of um
milk dripping out of his beard and asked
me if i wanted some milky
dude
jessica you're tripping balls dude
i thought i was it was crazy well thank
you to the baby
i'm glad you're doing okay thank you to
the baby
saved
jessica ladies and gentlemen
what a follow-up i'm so
so glad
to have that confirmation i'm so glad
she called in maybe you are very hero
maybe the hero maybe you are a hero very
unfortunate what's happening to her now
but
oh here i have the winner of team skeet
merch giveaway on twitter by reef
tweeting a photo of gary nice this is
from alex alex
the lucky winner of the team skeet
giveaway team ski better start paying me
at this point smash that like button
promoting them too much
hmm all right i got videos let's watch
video snoop dogg
to people who say
that you can be high 24 7
and it not affect you
this is what i present to you snoop dogg
literally left his stream on mute for a
week
without knowing
the dude was streaming for a week
on mute this is the funniest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever and for some reason he said
his chat to emojis only
and this this is his stream obviously
there's no sound but he was streaming
all week with no audio
and so
you know they're trying to tell him with
just emojis
that his [ __ ] is muted and it's just a
microphone that says nay
and uh
name microphone dude
no microphone dude the one thing about
the clip is you can't really see what
he's doing yeah he's also just
like a [ __ ] black dark stream to be
honest
i'm assuming that like twitch
paid him to stream
and he is like delivering
on the least possible
in the least possible way
just how do you turn your chat to me
emoji only that's pretty epic i want to
try that
can we try that
we don't stream on twitch anymore yeah
but is there emoji only chat for youtube
no i don't think so nate audio
[ __ ] awesome dude
here
all of snoop's last six streams have
been dead silent
but that hasn't stopped people from
tuning in to watch him inaudibly play
madden while he has a few joints people
have tried to let him know he's muted
but his chat is emote only meaning that
people are trying to help him having
cryptic having to cryptically convey the
issue through a series of emojis
this was cracking me up bro
nay microphone
oh my god oh [ __ ] there was a no way
yeah i did you didn't know about this no
yeah i guess there's a little fresh
hoodie in the back of uh
he's all that
so now we love them i love that movie
with that movie
go on imdb and give that [ __ ] a
10. or an honest review let's be an
honest review an honest review
we don't tell people give it a 10
or less or less
i i i ironically i do think the move is
fun
i don't remember the chat is starting to
to just uh voluntarily go emoji only
which i appreciate i want to see the
chat emoji only yeah
yeah yeah all right please please people
emoji only from now on let's see what we
can do decrypt messages emoji only
it'll be fun an honest review an honest
review here let me do chat let me show
this review
let's see
oh i don't see a lot of emojis
well
well there was
okay i guess whatever
um let's remember earlier
when snoop dogg had a gamer rage moment
at madden 21
which we use that sound by all the time
of him screaming [ __ ]
it's awesome dude snoop is having he's
having such a bad time on
twitch the worst decision he's made look
how angry he is bro look at his face
[Applause]
[ __ ] came in this [ __ ] moment all
my [ __ ] day
bro
this is the worst ad for weed ever
wait is it muted what happened
dude he's so pissed at this game
it's rage quitting
yep
i love that for him
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
new blind up about
[Music]
snoop lion
oh
lord
oh here's another one this was olivia's
fine so there's this german family
this is the uh the german band
family band right
were they german i think they're just
really well they're american they're
american but they're very popular in
germany oh oh oh oh oh okay
interesting uh actually cam found this
okay i'm found there cam just randomly
sent it to me one night with no
commentary i was just like
kelly family apparently from a very
dysfunctional family they all lived in a
trailer obviously you know they've got
to be dysfunctional
they sold over 20 million albums
and but this is so odd they were ranked
sixth most popular music act in germany
in the 1990s
and here's one of their big hit songs
i never heard this
but it sure was interesting
here is
the kelly family
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
tonight germany's sixth most popular
musical kids out there stop it
[Music]
right now
yeah
classic guys
and highly educational doing
motivational
motivational right it's like a mantra
yeah i feel very motivated kids telling
themselves over and over again
they're so beautiful pull them up pull
them up let's take a look pull what up
oh fred yeah
you're so beautiful yeah
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
alfredo
[Applause]
[Music]
hi freddy i love you so much
you're so sweet everybody i love freedom
everybody loves you
you're such a beautiful soul
thank you
thank you
thank you
you're such a sweet dog
i love you so much
you mean the world to me
[Music]
i love you
you're the best
wow
are you like you how are you how do you
exist i know it was you fredo how do you
exist
i'm so special
[Music]
you're so special
such a good boy
you want some love come here
[Music]
yeah
hey daddy
daddy
you are such a sweetie boy
nope not having it
trader's a diva
we just did a special moment with
alfredo ladies and gentlemen
alfredo
thank you so much all right let's go
through the gambit of videos we've got
doctor disrespect is suing twitch i find
i am captivated by the story or lack
thereof
but he did break his silence recently
in a little bit of a way
which i find interesting here and off my
little discussion here all right because
i
there's a reason why i don't talk about
it i mean i can't talk about
stuff
all righty righty writing i can't talk
about it but a lot of people ask me do
you know the reason yeah i do know the
reason why now i've known for months now
the reason why
and i'll just say this right now champs
there's a reason why
we're suing the [ __ ] out of them okay
uh i don't know how else to put it the
amount of damages and and you just don't
no
no
um
got a
second i i
anyways
it's been i mean
you just got to think of what's of what
the purple snakes platform is
and and the end of my little discussion
here yes all right because i
there's a reason why i don't talk about
it i mean i can't talk about
stuff
all righty right so um
what is it called the purple snake
such as a dis yes
just calling it snakey so i'm so [ __ ]
interested on why he got banned
i mean so he so i first of all he found
out so that's good
the truth is out there somewhere
if you guys who don't know doctor
disrespect was like the number one
streamer on twitch super hyped super
like to the moon
um
huge character
just signed a huge contract with twitch
and like did this huge beautiful
promotion with them too like this
unbelievable commercial he did with them
that was so cool yeah and then just out
of nowhere
completely banned him
with zero explanation nobody knows why
there was lots of speculation about
people speculated that it was because
they didn't want to pay him his contract
or something stupid which i don't think
is just based on money
there was someone who was putting forth
accusations that he was involved in some
allegations
that obviously those claims have
absolutely no have no substance
really none of it i mean there were a
lot of theories
and all of them were things that
within a span of time
likely would have come out and
nothing we know nothing it's pretty
amazing in this day and age
for something so big like that on the
internet to happen and for information
not to leak out
yeah
but you know the fact that he knows
and he's suing
i kind of i don't know why but i feel
like
so this one got the essay uh theory came
from this guy
what's his name the e reporter guy
i don't know if he ever said that
explicitly yeah i didn't no somebody
said it didn't they
no
nobody would say what he said was i
heard the reason and it's so bad
that yeah there's a lot been lots of
that kind of stuff but no there's
there's no
there's no solid information whatsoever
god i want to [ __ ] know so bad i'm
hoping that when this lawsuit goes
forward
that these documents will be public
right i mean unless they sealed them for
some reason
yeah somebody in the chat said what
about the bathroom filming that happened
a while before and he got punished for
that and then
completed his suspension or whatever
and the banning happened quite a
you know six months after that so the
bathroom incident he went into a
bathroom and was filming at an event
and um
like dan said he got suspended for that
so
no that wouldn't that wouldn't cause
them to get banned unless maybe there
was uh
some follow-up to it yeah i guess
yeah but it seemed like that was a dead
issue at the time that he actually got
permanently banned like he had already
served his punishment
so yes so slasher said yeah there was
some spec i got i just want to know so
bad
some people are saying that's right
leading up to his his ban he was talking
about all this crazy conspiracy theory
[ __ ] there was that
yeah some people are saying covid
misinformation i don't know if he spread
covet misinfo but i remember he was on
some wild conspiracy theory [ __ ]
uh right leading up to his band
19.
he he said in a different clip that uh
he lost all these sponsorships and brand
deals and abilities to work with places
like netflix and disney because when you
google his name there's the ban
and that not knowing has affected his
you know sponsorships oh so
you'd have to assume if he's going to
jump into a lawsuit like this
whatever it is must not be
that bad
that
like
if if for an allegation or something
that would be way worse to come out for
his sponsorship i disagree because at
this point
he has nothing left to lose
nobody wants to work with him and i
agree he's got a legitimate claim to
damages depending on what like the level
of proof that they have right
but if it was something horrible like
essay
then um he would want first of all he
has nothing left to lose and
he'll be he's going to want to refute
the claim so
i i disagree that that negates the
if it's something bad it could have been
just something like covet misinformation
though because people were just getting
slum slammed on left and right for that
yeah
but like you said he had like a huge
contract with twitch and like how flimsy
was
his contract if
they were able to just unilaterally
kick them off the platform like that
with like no warning and no
further information it's just weird
it's weird people are guessing that he
got banned for misinfo
that he's think it's a free speech i i
can't [ __ ] wait to see that complaint
bro
people are guessing it's deaf noodles
it's not deaf noodles is it dr drew it's
not dr drew
yeah me and dr drew are making a podcast
together dedicated to just analyzing
trisha videos
every new trisha video i think a lot of
people might watch that
oh did you guys see that jeff whitaker
was doing the [ __ ] crate challenge
i sure did like dude
this [ __ ] guy
got a traumatic brain injury from david
dubrick
and then he's doing a [ __ ] crate
challenge for david dobrik video
dude
what the [ __ ]
i mean look obviously i don't think
i think
jeff
likes doing risky [ __ ] he's like an
adrenaline junkie or something but why
is david allowing him to do this
the man has a traumatic brain injury why
is he doing great challenge nonsense
okay ethan
anyone with me i was like come on bro
i thought it was a little corny to do
this
that's all else no comment
well every time i mention jeff he like
threatens me in the dms
yeah i didn't know if you wanted to say
that
i'm not i have nothing to hide i mean i
think he's just unwell and stuff so i
don't want to go in on him but like
sometimes i hesitate like i talk about
everyone right but every time i mention
him the [ __ ] just straight up
threatens me
jeff and lil tracy yeah i can't mention
those guys are like pulled through guys
i want to read this
someone who called it don't worry
can i just read a part of it no don't
really what'd you say olivia someone who
called in um
said that they were listening to a
little tracy live stream
and
they said that
he said he was a big h3 fan
no
it was on the queue
why does he keep trying to fight me
every time i mentioned yeah no i put it
on that would explain why he
well they're they're still in the queue
do you want to speak to this person yeah
bring him up here's eric right now
yes a little tracy eric are you there
yes hello okay so eric is little tracy a
fan why does he want to fight me all the
time i mention him
uh he i i believe the reason he wants to
i put quote-unquote fight you it's like
that's his type of humor oh you think
he's goofy but he blocked me
i think he's
after he said not to talk about him you
know
wait wait wait wait hold on i mean if
he's just goofing this whole time that
it's honestly
at 2 a.m uh he was on a live stream on 2
a.m and he was answering fan questions
and um somebody said like what's the
beef with h3 and he said oh well there's
no beef i'm a fan of that guy oh and
then that's it that was that's why he
said yeah i hope that's
also
this past weekend one of his uh friends
tragically passed away too oh
that's horrible i'm so sorry yeah damn
and like you started off the show uh
just like
joking on them and stuff like that
it's
let me see if i'm blocked
well tracy
let's see because if he i i mean if he
blocked me that doesn't seem like
is he tracy minaj with a bunch of jays
is this no yeah that's him wait that no
that can't yeah
you're close friends with uh post call
post malone
and he was close friends with too
and like that you guys have like
like a connection too you know like
you're he was also like uh close of peep
and i remember uh you brought post on
and talked about peep and well
tragically passed away too
and now one of his other friends passed
away this weekend and like
i don't know if he's gonna he's probably
gonna see this show right now too he'll
be like oh he's gonna tweet me again
okay i'm trying to find his i cannot
find this dude's twitter i
could be wrong but um
um he might have been suspended on the
twitter oh was he banned on twitter do
you know
yeah i believe so yeah yeah
yeah he's on instagram
like late at night and fans talk to him
and all that stuff well next yeah like
it looks like a couple months ago it was
like 7 a.m and some people said like
there's no beef like i like that guy and
all that stuff
okay yo well next time he um is doing a
live here ethan what's his instagram
i'll just send it to you and what's up
okay a little tracy manoj also i want to
submit uh you could tell ela a teddy
fresh collaboration idea
what you got uh smokey the bear
collaboration with teddy fresh would be
pretty cool
stay tuned
may be happening sooner than you think
with all the california fires going on
right now
that's a great idea i hope someone here
thought of that
no actually that's that's really funny
you say that um
that's something
well the [ __ ] cat yeah we've been
working on that for like a year it's
coming out and i think next month
and it's a sick bro [ __ ] sick
time
what's up
can i get a hat or something hell yeah
we'll get your email from one of the
screeners yeah i'll put you back once
once we're off the air we'll uh grab
your info we'll we'll hook you up just
for uh thanks for being so on point with
that i want to thank from the bottom i
heard that you guys were going to be at
complexcon
who'd you hear that from
somebody lied to you you said that on uh
i said that no we won't be a complex guy
oh no
no no i'm not right now sorry bro
i have a next i have a connection at
complex comp
and like if you want to get uh teddy
fresh a boost there well i got the hook
up just let me know oh cool thank you
bro we'll get your email all right
yeah stay on the line all right don't
hang up i'm gonna
i'm gonna put you back on hold oh go
ahead
yep i i also like you say you're a big
uh beatles fan are you ready for the let
it be movie
is that a new movie i wasn't aware of it
yeah peter jackson is uh
gonna come out
do you not know about that that actually
is really cool yeah oh is it like a
documentary yeah yeah
oh it's old footage oh yeah
i'm all going to be all over there
that's exciting yeah that does look like
hours and hours and hours of footage
yeah apparently they were reporting on
multiple cameras like the entire time
during the recording sessions of let it
be and all of that footage has been in
storage
pretty much since then peter jackson got
his hands on all of it restored it all
and is cutting a documentary out of it
that's exciting
i'm hoping
yeah i'm hoping he can do some kind of
scene where he cgs them into a barrel
over a waterfall and
like the hobbit yes you're making a hot
river
no that's that's great thank you eric
eric you're the man standing on
everybody
don't hang up take care we'll get your
info don't hang up yeah actually so cats
have a bag
the smokey collection is coming together
so [ __ ] good
and
it's really exciting because
you know a portion of it is gonna go to
uh the foresting whatever government
agency you know it's owned by by the
government the smoke of the bear license
the ip by the forest
so it does feel great
but the government gets enough of my
goddamn money yeah but it goes straight
to the good guys okay doesn't go to like
[ __ ] bombs to drop on like villagers
and okay well that's good the
countryside somewhere
eric
what a cool dude on the ball so little
tracy doing these
lives on ig all the time you know what
you have to do
should i make an ig and
commit war on him
that that no that's not all what i was
planning on suggesting you gotta join
his live oh but he doesn't even follow
me on instagram well
here let's correct that
well tracy if you're watching this this
is an olive branch
[Music]
this is an offering of peace
and love little tracy i cannot find your
[ __ ] accounts everywhere bro can you
just have a normal social name just
i know but if i type little tracy on
instagram it should find his account
like what
yes i did something to piss off the
instagram gods tracy minaj
all right so i'm gonna follow him
i found his twitter account
you did
it has 100 or 300 followers yeah i don't
that's how do you know it's real that's
why it's linked on his website
oh
so i found that one and thought it was
fake because it only had 100 followers
okay he's got a little kawaii oh
a b coming out with some dark details
there
all right
that's that fun's over with that
because he has allegations i don't know
you want to clarify me
no who what
no oh
ouch
let me unfollow him real quick
not bad huh
let's just say this will get him but
banned on tw
let's just say this would get him banned
on twitch
well he is no longer a fan of yours
oh my god
people do not want him part of the
cannon
heard you
out in clear loud and clear
[Music]
okay so this is a highly requested video
this i'm excited to watch this um seven
high schoolers decide who amongst them
wins a thousand dollars this is fun
apparently this is a fun video to react
to
so i've been looking forward to this
let's watch
you guys want pizza or burgers
pizza break it happen oh
i want a second burger
oh
just please whatever we get not vegan oh
yes
and i don't want shake shack i want like
a real burger i don't want a fast food
burger i want like a [ __ ] like come
on
like a baby
i need that i want you in my belly
or
someone want to look into that
so we're going with burgers
birds we can get both i mean who says we
can't get both
we definitely have to get bold let me
see why the dogs are freaking out
all right i'm gonna start this this
video
seven high schoolers decide
i think we should describe everyone's
situation for example i just don't want
anybody to leave with their feelings
hurt or feeling like my problems aren't
big enough jeff can you turn the volume
up a bit
thank you sir
[Music]
so just gonna get lord of the flies like
real cutthroat
you know what happened
hi you guys hi hi hi
what do you guys all have in common we
are from high school we're all in high
school
what's high school like right now it's
hell
yeah yeah it's a [ __ ] prison holy
[ __ ]
the game is thousand to one you decide
who leaves with a thousand dollars we're
gonna do four elimination rounds if you
cannot decide nobody gets the money
round one begins i think we should
describe everyone's situation for us
very briefly because somebody doesn't
have one we could do it that way or we
could do like we have competitions like
i feel like competitions isn't the best
i just don't want anybody to leave with
their feelings hurt or feeling like my
problems aren't big enough and i feel
ashamed for talking about what well no
one will feel you know well you don't
know that though if somebody says
something super personal that they wish
they hadn't said because they didn't end
up getting the money and it didn't help
them you know that could feel like
really bad or people could feel like
ashamed about their problems they're
like my problems aren't as big out
she's the first they cut her ass out
i didn't watch someone olivia i was just
thinking she's god yeah i would cut this
yeah she would be the first one for me
bye but i love that they'll look at each
other at the same time she's cut
be like
oh man my life sucks but i didn't get
the money but because we're in a
timeline i feel like we should just like
have someone like say why they need the
one thousand dollars in the end we can
just all collectively okay so our
thoughts what i would do with one
thousand dollars is help start uh online
clothing business what kind of clothing
will you be selling
just like t-shirts and more like
streetwear oriented i don't know like
music artists something to do with like
popcorn
i mean playstation 5.
i want the one thousand dollars from
education i'm in full ib so for each
test that you take you have to pay a
certain amount i'm a senior right now
and just want to
put the money towards college and being
able to afford like textbooks and
college tuition so
well obviously be cool to like take my
girl out or get a gucci belt or
something but this is a real man right
here okay all right gucci belt y'all are
fine you're all ready to but fun to
gucci belt couple classes
in my high school that has college
credits towards it and it's like a good
six hundred dollars i need the other 400
because my sister like handed me down
her car but like it's beat up i needed
money to
fix that so most of my money would go to
like paying my car insurance and my like
school fees and then on top of that i
got invited to a wedding in florida
whatever i had left over i'd try to get
a good plane ticket over there nope i
like a sec
cutter she's out she's out
open the floor underneath her just drop
her ass in the bed
yo just get me whatever the burger i
just want a cheeseburger and fries i
want a double cheeseburger and fries
with dog [ __ ]
that's how i feel when i eat it i want a
double cheeseburger with french fries
and a diarrhea which i'm going to be
having later tonight on it
i'll have the same okay
thank you olivia there so i could be at
the wedding i want to be a marine
biologist when i grow up
i love the ocean i love animals it's
just where i get my happiness from
really there's this trip to the bahamas
which is very very expensive and the
thousand dollars would help me go to
that i feel like it'd be super cool
experience is it like a trip through
your school or like no
so it's just a personal interest they
don't love this i don't mind it she's
being honest um
you don't like it well the other kids
are like i'm gonna start a street brand
company with the duck yeah but does it
have to be the bahamas bro she kind of
she these kids are all going to buy
playstation 5. yeah
you don't like that she's going to the
bahamas little bougie yeah i mean i
don't they found seven kids that are
really unlikable none of us none of them
are like i'm done i'm starving like my
younger sibling isn't eating in the two
days that's true but yeah i wish someone
was just like yeah i want an xbox my mom
can't afford her medicine
you know what i mean thank you okay in
my current home i'm pretty much left to
fund myself basically and it really
sucks because the school that i go to um
they don't do supply buses to my house
area so i have to take uber's like
everywhere
wait how did she afford that uber
oh they dig into this okay these
maybe
maybe they talk about it i know cody co
watched this video either he talked
about it or they talk about it how the
there's no [ __ ] way a kid could uber
to school every day that would cost
thousands a month that's bougie as hell
expensive yes it's like a lot of stress
on me and it's like i'm sorry i'm
getting emotional
it's oh love you're doubting it
yeah
there's well if she can drive uber to
school every day already she has enough
money right that's actually like the
biggest flex of any of these kids by far
like i'm being forced to grow up so fast
and i'm only 16.
what's funny about her is that she could
be like the most spoiled but she
actually believes that her life is that
challenging
you know
my dad only bought me a mercedes c-class
and home and you know it's just so
embarrassing because all my friends have
g-wagons
nina were you the one that said we
shouldn't do what we just did
yes
why
i don't i think it can make people feel
like their reasons aren't good enough
yeah
kids out there
stop that
money or give him the money for this
reason or that reason and not to say
that that isn't valid
but everybody else is also valid and so
i think if we decided through like a
random competition
that's a way that nobody could feel
attacked i think they should just show
me your house show me where you live
parker let's all show our house give me
the google street views
you know what i mean
doctor feel hurt by specific people i
feel the opposite you can tell real fast
who needs it and who deserves it because
if she's working really hard and if
she's trying to just get through is this
even moral like this is so [ __ ] to put
these kids together and make them fight
for a thousand dollars man this i mean
it's entertaining it's super interesting
but it's like serious lord of the flies
[ __ ] like they're five minutes away from
banging this girl's head open with a
brick
they're just gonna start killing them
what like piggy oh yeah picking that
rock dude absolutely just like piggy
that's a bigger reason than like buying
a plane ticket or going on a trip or
something like that i don't want it to
seem like i'm coming off like oh i'm
using that
that's like your reason i don't want
anybody to feel bad like i don't feel
comfortable talking about the stuff i
have going on at home that would make a
difference in like i know we all have
stuff going on that we just need to
bring out cookies you have a minute and
ten seconds okay
guys we need to like
we need to vote okay this is
one vote for me
these kids did not make compelling thank
you who wrote that
me i don't know how to spell his name
i'm sorry
uh
one for colleen
obviously one for nina they all voted
for themselves
another one for me and one for ej so
there's a tie yeah how do you guys want
to do it vote again or do you want them
to decide just vote just vote
i know i'm going to be out
she wanted to go to the bahamas so bad i
don't know everyone has something
against me so
get her the [ __ ] out i hear
she's in high school let's remember you
know
it's hard to but like i mean the girls
was basically i want to go on a trip to
the bahamas so
that's not winning hearts and minds i
can't do all this amy go ahead you guys
seem to have some kind of trauma
unlocked from this no i mean i just
spoiled kids i worked at auto parts
factory when i was 16. i don't want to
hear from these little shits
what would you have said to get the
thousand dollars i'm trying to chill
dude i want an xbox some jays
that's the real that's the honest answer
honest yeah
she's like look dude i hate my parents
they hate me i like the twilight movies
[ __ ] hate my life just give me the
money bro
i wonder if that would work anything
else see this is what i didn't want to
happen if somebody gets hurt by what's
happening
you're saying like everybody has
something against me so if we did random
competitions nobody would feel that yeah
that's a good idea i have one for khalid
one for jordan two for khalid three for
khalid and one for jordan
sorry college no it's three to two sorry
oh so he got his ass got eliminated wait
what happened
why did he get eliminated
were they
what just happened
yeah i think i was wrong too olivia do
you were they voting for someone to
leave yeah they were voting for who that
so they'll put it off oh
wait so the bahama girl why was she
about her she wouldn't even get a vote
wait maybe i'm wrong
no i think you're right you had votes
right
yeah this what what did this kid ask for
that
that's why she was upset because she got
two votes he's the streetwear kid okay
fair enough yeah that's that's yeah
fair enough see you later dude how's
everybody doing
it was so it was like they're like and
let's be honest it ain't happening dude
that was deep bye-bye i'm just kidding
this kid could be the next big thing i
don't know okay
yeah i mean i kind of expected it i mean
going into this i kind of expected to be
the first one out
i love him oh i have nothing against any
of you you guys ready yeah yes right all
right we've started i feel like we
should do something fun you know
something to bring up the mood i think
we should do random stuff like who can
name the most
countries in europe who can
three two one foot up
i'm buddhist everybody so i don't know
it's like 10 times a day like churros
just to like throw you guys off how
about you guys have to like spin around
oh it feels
all right how about you stop since i
don't know if you guys are busy
oh bahamas the buddhists
she's oh how do you feel do you think
that was fair during the
no
what you say no
the bahama girl i do this ten times a
day she just said well you should have
done it eleven yeah
one more practice i guess
abe hates that girl i don't hate her i
just hate that she's
she gets pretty crazy i don't like
spoiled people i'll say that but i wish
her the best she seems sweet no you hate
her you can hate a child hates a strong
word but
oh no it's not fair
i don't think anybody had like an upper
hand tonight i'll be hella mean i'll be
so mean whoa whoa
oh my god girl
so we're not gonna listen to the couch
right guys who's the leader here
nina
i feel like it's the three of us nina
you're not gonna lie
oh she's going for kids
the bahama girl is vicious oh my gosh
maybe she maybe she does need the
vacation of the bahamas she seems pretty
tightly wound man
i don't know maybe she was telling the
truth
i heard it very well
well i think that i think you're saying
that because in the very beginning i was
like let's do challenges
and no i'm not saying that because of
that you keep influencing everyone how
yeah how am i influencing girl it's a
five minute video i mean they've been
going for like five minutes
i'm all in on this i don't know about
you guys yeah i'm fascinated i'm very
curious yeah i'm captivated
i think she's just trying to make
everything worse is it cool this guy's
awesome on the couch for a little bit
because this is between inclusion us
five do people agree why are you just
sitting
what was your reasoning again nj um pay
for my ib testing ej what about you
what are you gonna do with the money for
your girlfriend i was gonna take her out
probably two nights at dinner she has
like some car insurance that she needs
to pay off so i would help her with that
if he needs it for his girlfriend then i
think his girlfriend would have been a
better candidate to come on the set but
that's the thing
she's right
i agree the girls got up there gonna buy
a gucci bag just now yeah the dude said
he want to buy a gucci belt take his
girl out i mean come on at least buy an
xbox that's you know xbox or forever
dinners for one night
that wasn't my reason my reason was
school fees
it's a lot deeper than what i said but i
don't want to get into it because it's
like that
like i have to pay for school stuff but
the reasoning underneath that is that
like my family also can't pay for it and
stuff that i like nobody knows and like
i'm not allowed to talk about so i
literally like even though i want to use
it this girl's tricky she is using it
they're all doing that they're all now
the story's deeper there's actually more
to it it's not just dinner
i can't tell you but there's it's deeper
than actually my mom fell down the
stairs and she hasn't moved in 10 years
and my dad left
he's in prison
and my brother
this is awesome as a reason and only for
a thousand bucks this is like the lowest
budget highest entertainment value
possible
thousand dollars
because it is valid like i can't
so can we think of anything else we can
do that's like i think someone else read
like
green light
what can we do ej
you want to do something physical
something like a quiz that quiz sounds
pretty yeah we can do like a quiz on
nj
nj oh that's easy oh that's ej sorry oh
that's confusing yeah nj ej
what's happening why are they voting
oh i thought they said they're gonna do
a quiz they're just randomly voting
oh my gosh
ej
those are the guys all right
you're really nice i really like john pj
come join us
how are you doing
it sucks it does like i ain't i'm not
finna count it sucks
but
they chose are you guys ready think of
something fun creative outside of the
box that we can use how about the
drawing contest all right let's have a
drawing contest then sure and then are
we voting or who's voting let's have the
council no because they have their
preferences
so we don't know whose it is
okay
wait okay what are we going to draw
we'll let them decide draw like an
octopus okay
[Music]
god dang it oh i messed up already
you guys want to play like rock paper
scissors together
i'm
chilling is also probably how like
children would decide we're we're
literally children this is going to be
the best damn octopus i've ever drawn
so how's your girlfriend
oh come on
okay this one
that's cute it has a little blush in
little kawaii cheeks
ali the octo
is hungry good drawing the next octopus
to be honest it's a little scary the
eyes are like to be honest with you kind
of creeping me off and then this one
it's another little creepy one but
you know it's all right
actually the eyes are kind of on point
though because they do kind of come out
so the one that we picked i already see
it where the loser
is the scary one
okay i'm out oh no
i'm so sorry i feel really bad hi guys
i'll have a stomach ache oh my god how
do you guys feel about that like how we
did that last voting i liked it but i
also didn't like it
it was fair do you guys think this round
was more fair than the previous rounds
yeah
for sure did you want me out did you
want me out no actually like
most of the people that i won in the
final three are there
but just like not all of them would you
say i said most of the people on the
couch right now are what i wanted on the
final three oh
thank you most
no
i feel like we should for this last run
we should like you know obviously state
our opinions do you guys want our
opinions or no no
this is as long as we don't like know
that they're singing one of us out or
something then i think that's fair okay
yeah we'll hear it sure i'd say
heather
i don't know you just like have an
impact on me am i supposed to know which
one's heather what do you think
um
i would say heather too oh she don't
take it that's heather katie oh she's
the poor girl who has to pay for uber
every day the poor millionaire
dude heather
you like they're pitying me is like if
you need it you need it like i would
also say heather i honestly think that
she needs it earlier i said heather
uber
um decision
hearing everyone's you know opinions and
like everyone's stories
i cannot compare myself to what you two
are going through
i live in a city where there's a lot
what the [ __ ] are we talking about
that's the bougiest [ __ ] i've ever heard
from a kid
things accessible
i have a job you know i have you have a
job get the [ __ ] out of here sporting
parents so i just want i want to
vote myself off just because you guys
deserve you deserve it a lot more than i
do i'm definitely gonna vote but
it's gonna be kind of hard so i'm opting
myself out
what a legend so like specifically what
are you gonna use some money for cuz i
know you have like a lot of stuff oh
this now this is gonna get good
because both these girls want it bad
going on i would primarily use it for a
car because
my main thing is transportation and
getting around because of cars what are
you gonna buy for a thousand dollars
like forgetting their 10 bucks getting
back 10 bucks going to work 10 bucks
it's a lot of money oh my god where are
you getting that money from
when she goes to work
should boss push your base for her own
ubers
are you doubting ab
i don't know i'm gonna hear them out and
hear the case okay i'm getting ahead of
myself
i don't know i just i'm not buying the
uber plea
yeah going straight to transportation i
could be using it for better things like
for school how many hours a week do you
work upwards of 30. okay so you were
like a full job and then you're also
doing school on top of that
is it possible to work 30 hours in high
school that's almost full time it
depends on the state
she said 30 hours a week
that's what i heard yeah
bro that is lying she i think she's
lying
dude that's almost full-time job while
going to high school i don't buy it yeah
of course not
but maybe i'm an [ __ ] maybe i'm an
[ __ ]
you probably work that many hours
because you have to like to pay for like
food and new transportation and stuff
i mean i'm going to give it to heather
if you are
cool with that yeah i'm totally fine i
think we're going to give it to heather
wow
i just feel really bad this is not
that's not a pity thing this is
obviously a really big need so yeah yeah
we're set
okay that was nice they came together
i'm doubting heather i am doubting
the kids the kids were nice
[Applause]
how was this experience for you guys it
was does this get any more interesting
olivia it's pretty much over yeah we're
at the end so what do you guys think
what's hap hmm
i want to do a deep environment
yeah i try to read the comments but
they're turned off
oh for real that people probably went
crazy on heather
wait what's our chat saying
you guys buy this well there are a lot
of people saying
you know
like i said it it's a per state thing um
how many hours is a miner like work
i mean if you work full shifts saturday
sunday i guess technically it's possible
but like people are someone said i used
to work 35 hours a week at 15. in high
school i mean okay shout out i mean
that's tough man people are saying 40
hours a week in high school okay fair
enough men you guys you guys had it
harder than me that that's that's real
yeah remember i [ __ ] in california you
have to get a work well
it's been a long time since i was a
teenager trying to get a job but yeah at
the time you had to get a work permit
and stuff from the school
to even be able to work
someone said i feel bad that high
schools have to work 30 hours yeah i
mean that that's great i mean high
school is a lot of work
i was getting paid under the table where
i worked
they were working like crazy doubles
sometimes but it wasn't straight
yeah she said at an auto parts place
in a game
any game in minecraft
i don't think i don't think anyone's
looking my first job was under the table
as well my first job was under the table
from my dad oh
my [ __ ] dad i got stories about my
dad i worked at a deli
the old italian deli that's pretty crazy
and like you didn't know them
you didn't know them no pay you under
the table that's so sketchy
that was the way it was it's kind of
like free labor of like base like i'm an
employer now and paying someone minimum
wage on the table is literally free
labor
like it's so little money right compared
to the operating of your business yeah
and actually paying payroll tax and all
that i mean it's free labor
well they got what they paid for because
i was supposed to say
here i was supposed to park
they're probably some [ __ ] up fords
out there i didn't do a good job
hopefully no one died because of you
hopefully not but
a lot of people here are saying they
worked 40 to 30 to 40 hours a week man
i'm sorry for you guys that our country
is absolutely doomed
like i i'm really sorry man and maybe
she it seems like maybe she's telling
the truth because a lot of people are
saying i used to work that much in high
school i mean in high school i would
do people saying that's normal i don't
think it's normal to work 30 hours a
week in high school just like that's a
lot and school is a lot of work man i
just that seems [ __ ] up the kids like
i understand getting a summer job
right yeah i understand getting a summer
job but during the school year having to
work 30 hours a week it's just yeah i'm
thinking about it maybe not 30 but
probably like 25 or so is what i worked
you worked during high school yeah yeah
i was gonna say yeah same here yeah
senior year right that's kind of normal
maybe i'm just a spoiled douche i talk
guitar lessons
if you're in high school now you'll be
taking ubers every day
i know
my parents said i used to go to school
my parents wouldn't give me money and
they didn't make me a lunch i would just
starve
you just i just starve i would beg for
food from my friends
straight up i would beg for food from my
friend
homeless child
well no my parents would say if you want
to be fair to them they would say
pack your own lunch right so
i would pocket my lunch money and then
the girl my girlfriend at the time got
free lunch and so i just eat half of
hers that's awesome
how much money they give you for lunch
they give you is like a five dollar
limit basically so it was like the lunch
and then you could get like one side one
extra item
like people are yelling at me hold on p
there's some people angry they're saying
oh
message deleted
i'm reading california rules that
you could work like 40 hours
as a 16 year old
right i guess the work permit is just
below 16. dude people it was like if you
wanted to work like you're at it
i just can't imagine like focusing and
doing a good job in school and working
40 hours at the same time well you also
did like extracurricular curricular
activities as well right yeah i was all
into like ap and all that dumb [ __ ] yeah
and like water polo and of course yeah
people say it's normal uh well listen to
all the people out there who are working
in high school i mean
i that sounds real tough and you know
good for you for doing what you got to
do i think it's unfortunate we live in a
country where kids have to actually work
instead of just [ __ ] learning
um and enjoying high school
that's just that's a hard life like i
said i used to work during the summer
part-time
for sure
right
yeah i mean i mostly worked just because
i wanted to have my own money well
most people who do it i'm sure are doing
it by necessity someone's saying
30 hours is just six hours five days a
week yeah and you go to school for six
hours a day and you have a ch i had a
shitload of homework how the [ __ ] are
you going to be busy for 12 hours and
then go home and do like three hours of
homework
slamming
grinding it doesn't make sense
i mean people are acting like i'm crazy
but i mean i don't think kids should
have to work
30 hours a week in high school that's
crazy
yeah people saying it's normal i don't
think it's
damn i mainly did it around 16 17 to
prepare to have enough money to
go to college and afford to rent a room
and stuff like that so you kind of have
to to prep if to go to the next stage if
you're not
you know set up for that i guess
this girl said i worked 30 hours a week
at chuck e cheese when i was 16 in high
school for nine bucks an hour and help
my mom with rent bro that's a hard life
[ __ ] i'm i mean listen maybe i maybe i
had it better than most i mean i
definitely had it better than most but
like i just don't think people should
have to do that that sounds like really
hard man for a kid 16 years old yeah
you're not wrong about that it's
definitely
difficult someone said i would do my
homework at work what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] oh this country sucks you guys
you guys i'm sorry but you guys
shouldn't be having to work 30 40 hours
in high school i mean dude that's [ __ ]
up
y'all should really not have to do that
it's just like how are you going to be
expected to actually do good work in
high school and learn and prepare for
well i guess to be fair i didn't so so i
guess i'm out of touch i don't know did
you guys start school early like seven
o'clock here or
is that just a michigan thing no we
should my school started real early it's
crazy it was an optional thing for
eight though or eight thirty they called
it zero period
yeah before
we had oh look at love flying that flag
i saw that hey get that out of here
this is
that's scary that's social as [ __ ] i'm
getting your [ __ ] out of here we don't
believe in socialism okay let me ask you
love because you live in associate a
social
a socialist utopia do kids well
do kids
oh well they have better conditions it's
definitely yes okay do kids in high
school work 30 40 hours a week
no not
that's a lot better than world war three
there you go we have so many jobs we do
a lot of summer jobs yeah summer jobs
make sense
to go to school yeah in sweden they pay
your ass to go to school because guess
what a better society when people get a
[ __ ] education and focus on actually
learning and being a kid it's not funny
that's the way it should be you all been
[ __ ]
lied to you've been fed slop
you've bought into this american dream
that has 16 year olds working 30 to 40
hours a [ __ ] week
to help their mom pay for rent
bro i am so disillusioned with this
country right now i'm sorry y'all
joe biden fika for life i'm sorry to
[Music]
[Applause]
i am so sorry to all you guys that had
to do that look at this look at this
tweet i put in uh discord speaking of
this country someone said most people
are poor 35 hours a week plus ap damn
god bless you man i mean that is just
hard man i i don't know what to say i
mean
really shout out to all your families
who had to do that
yeah
damn
my bus would come at 6 30 in the morning
i mean six i'm sorry six o'clock
so i had to be able like 5 30.
i don't know if that's normal but that
was the hardest part for me
that was for me waking uh high school
waking up i was so sleep deprived the
whole thing yeah that's what's crazy
about high school is that these kids are
sleep depressed what the [ __ ] go sir
what is this
wait why did he post this
you remember what ghosa right yeah he
got ghostered
this is the guy whose
whole family his brothers his sisters
made a [ __ ] they all collaborated to
make a video saying do not elect this
man now what is this dan well do you
know this like whole thing
this is like um
i guess it's
like a
the alpha male
red pilled circle basically has this
whole thing about posture okay and like
standing up straight
um and they they'll like post pictures
of like you know this guy is standing up
straight you see how this guy is like
you know at an angle towards the woman
that means he's like subservient to her
and interesting and so he
yeah today like an hour ago he turned
off replies with no replies
dude have you heard this guy talks the
most beta he's such a beta talker like
i've seen him talk and do speeches the
guy speaks straight beta he has no
confidence when he speaks
and he likes stutters
he doesn't have a stutter i'm not making
point people's stutters but he like he
speaks without confidence
i wouldn't be confident either if my
whole family was betraying me
doing a commercial no he's saying the
cactuses are not beta or not alpha he's
talking [ __ ] on cactuses
these cactuses are beta's [ __ ] dude
this is an alpha male right here guys
such a [ __ ] weirdo there are so many
creeps why would they reach
254.
yeah it was like an hour ago a little
over an hour ago
i love that replies are off
like kill to see the replies on that
well here hit i got a quote yeah yeah
i'm waiting this man plant some [ __ ]
cacti
this guy's flexing on cactus people yeah
i i don't know
i don't know what this is
this is this guy's like straight q and
so i'm sure he's something weird where
it's a dog i'm sure it's a dog whistle
to some white nationalist freaks
i think it has to be i i guess
beta male
beta
wow
this is so weird
yeah you should pull up a clip of him
talking because he really talks like a
little [ __ ]
let me see well there's that one clip of
him after uh january 6.
uh he was like i moved to uh forward the
whatever plan of
of uh sending the votes back and listen
to how he delivers that it's like
uh was he in in like a session is it
this
yeah yeah i think it's whatever thank
you madam chairwoman
never been accused of a crime there he
is mr biden calls january 6 the worst
attack since the civil war
a president was impeached for his
alleged role in that riot
it was reported early
totally unconfirmed real quick this
wasn't the video i was thinking okay but
just real quick let me run let me run
this back just a hair
i mean do you see
can you see this line right here oh [ __ ]
that posture you see this
look at the angle
that he is bowing that is subservient he
is bowing to this question
[Laughter]
that's a beta male if i've ever seen him
absolutely what was that
did you have like 20 tabs open oh no
it's because
it's the same reason that the yeah
okay low fps it's the same
it's the same reason that happened at
her up in this beach
i'm actually fascinated by all these
people saying how much they work my
mother works 16 hours
six days a week
is that
possible
yeah
i'm baited as [ __ ] my posture is
horrible
why is it the other guy's concerned with
beta and alpha like i never think about
this [ __ ] and i got married just fine
mm-hmm
you know
seems like the guys who are obsessed
with that [ __ ] might have other problems
i'm saying uh you don't say
yeah don't say you got that tim pool of
him saying it's not him it's the world
of course
i have it on speed dial
there's another one
if you i googled
tim pool it's not me it's everybody else
and the top result
is our video
awesome
what the [ __ ] that shit's crazy it's
cause yeah
it's a quirk of the way we have
everything routed here yeah here's the
uh the kinds of dudes who analyze
posture
you want to play that for me dan well
i'm trying to find the original
uh but it's i'm just finding all these
commentary videos making fun of him i
mean maybe it's this one dude i'm about
to be 34 yeah here it is
or and i have no family because my my
dad had two kids by the time he was 27
yeah and i'm like man
you know what you know what the problem
is though
it's definitely not me
i think it's
everybody else
the fact that you could actually say
that unironically and not catch yourself
olivia i heard you chuckling what do you
think
i think that's crazy
it's just a crazy statement right
i think the problem is everybody in the
world but me
he's so cool
here's what dr phil clip this one's been
making the rounds
dr phillip
[Music]
uh this
dude that
was like the sound of hell
oh so this guy got 150 000
of cosmetic surgery to make him look
like a k-pop idol and i think he's
trying to change his
he's trying to change his race to
korean
oh it's like a white guy and he's trying
to look korean yeah he's like straight
up i'm changing my rice to korean he
says if people can identify as
whatever gender they they feel like then
i should be able to do it identify as
any race that i want it's like what's
her name rachel
dozil or whatever right right right
right
what is the sound phil chill dude
to perfect my image
[Music]
we have to figure out what's going on
with british people we gotta we gotta
get one is there something going on with
british people have you looked at
america i'm still trying to figure out
what's going on with america yeah but
yeah
i just unloaded my shotgun at the
hurricane
i think it's slowing down
um there's so much wrong yeehaw what's
wrong with england
[Music]
i've been firing my gun over the
atlantic adam i'm gonna catch those
english
[Music]
yeah oh somebody's saying that this
is
that person's name is ollie
is that right and uh this person that's
on dr phil i don't know what about it
well just because i see a comment ali is
a troll
like trisha watch cherry eliza moe's
video exposing him wait how is he a
troll if he's got plastic surgery that
seems like way too committed what love
do we have a follow-up video on this or
is this the only one because i think
there's yeah i saw one recently that's
way better he actually did like
stretch his eyes that's the one i want
to watch yeah send me that one olivia
that's the one i want to watch i saw
that video and it blew my mind i thought
that was him
yeah he stretched his eyes to make
himself that's when he talks about how
he's switching his race to korean
yeah
yes this is him thank you olivia
oh my god this is the one
ollie london oh so this is uh
yeah
hey dr phil so i've just completed my
transition to look korean to look just
like jimin
this i think is my final procedure
to share this with you even though
you're probably gonna be so mad at me
like i know you're going to go crazy how
is this guy wrong next time you see me
tell me how is this a troll
the dude got plastic surgery to look
like a k-pop star
ugly you're disgusting i'm going to kill
you give me 200 okay dr phil that's
inappropriate for a doctor
that's because he told me not to do
anything you told me to love the real me
the love the real olly and uh
i did take your advice for like a year
but then i kind of just
changed my mind so please don't be mad
at me dr phil but i'm so happy to have
transitioned from british to korean i'm
now going to be identifying even more
identical than i already was so please
please don't be mad at me dr phil i hope
you like my new eyes i would love to
give you a wink right now but i can
really not even open my eyes someone
said someone's gotta tell me he doesn't
look like
what's his name
joomin that he's trying to look like did
you mean his headphones i don't want to
say it wrong because i'll get cancelled
um do the hey do the
jimin oh sorry if i mispronouncing his
name just remember i'm army
jimin jimin who's gonna tell me he
doesn't look like jimin he looks more
like a white lady
he transitioned to a karen
don't be mad don't send me to the ranch
as well i'm sending your ass to the
ranch bro you [ __ ] need that ranch
so here let's watch instantly fall in
love his lips just look so luscious and
kissable just on my lips alone so what's
wild about this guys he's not he's not
only transitioning to
korean
he's transitioning to a pull not like
literally a specific person jimin
right so he's like i'm jimin too
where did i see all this
blasium
jimin
army army army i love army
army
army
army
yes my lips would be 20 000. i've had my
jawbone completely shaved down i have my
chin bone shaved cut off that's not a
troll guys that's real screws and
brackets to keep my chin in place i had
my eyes done but now i want to change
that to make my eyes more almond shaped
just like jamin i also have my cheekbone
reduced i've also been he said almond
shaped he dodged a bullet there
he almost said something real racist you
know what i mean yeah he's like almond
shaped that's a good way to put it if
you don't want to get in trouble
my nose i've actually had surgery five
times bro it's not happening
my face is numb but i love it it's such
a great feeling my chin i can't even
feel can just feel the metal inside my
face my cheeks i have no feeling at all
so when i smile it actually feels
uncomfortable so
doing this it's it's it's weird
if i'm like kissing my eyes
or kissing one of my jimin pillows like
i can't feel anything it's terrible
he's also like in love with this person
it seems like much less in love and more
like he wants to kill him and wear his
skin yeah
pure
obsession
this is kind of giving me like a trisha
gerard way vibes
and uh
just standing fast
have you seen her last music video
i love lying in bed with bandages i'm
always at my happiest at that time he's
at his happiest right now he said
uh-huh
and i oop you know what this i mean
lincoln all right this person's
obviously very ill he's gonna say we'll
go easy very yeah disturbed it's not a
happy uh life
wanting to be human
heart a jew man i didn't say it's not
easy to be a jew man it's true that's
true as well
let me tell you
he's officially an animal crossing
character they got stung by a wasp
someone said
someone another one i'm korean he said
in a thick british accent
races aren't cosplay yeah i don't think
it's necessarily kosher to
transition to another race that i mean
obviously right this isn't something
that people are actually trying to do
there's no point of actually getting
like outraged because it's not like a
cultural movement to try to transition
to another way it's just some guy who's
a little bit [ __ ] stupid this is
mercifully an outlier yes yeah yeah of a
huge outlier
although trisha's been trying to
transition to being a jewish person for
a while now
you can technically do that by
approaching a rabbi
you're right there's no way to do that
no that one's fine
i heard she's
she's actually planning plastic surgery
to enlarge her nose so that's
interesting
oh my god
[Laughter]
jesus
it's time to end the show
we'll stop when the food gets here
i'm just having fun come on someone says
he is a troll what would you listen
there's voicemails i'm talking about
doing it for publicity okay send me the
voicemails let's see i'm listening send
me the voicemails the evidence that look
at my screen
you say there's a voicemail look at this
how what the [ __ ] is this
i don't know man
someone said 30 trisha videos incoming
whatever
i'm not talking about them i'm just
having a little fun
we're three hours in it's fine
yeah nobody watches that almost three
and a half hours the only reason i make
just having fun making gags and stuff
you know what i'm not going to get into
it
no trisha talk please yeah i agree i'm
sorry
just a little gag
just a gap it wasn't even really an
insult to her directly it was more just
offensive on its own terms for sure yeah
i'm not talking about trisha
yeah someone's saying it's a as a
plastic surgery addiction that is what
it is
okay so we'll have fun we'll keep going
about two months or something that you
know great feeling of wow i love my new
face kind of wears off and then i'm
always thinking about the next thing if
i have the eyebrow lift it'll make my
face very tight so i won't have any
expression and i'll just look you know
plastic fantastic i need to change
everything until i'm identical
it's not happening dude well lee has
undergone 15 surgeries in six years and
to change his looks now something i want
to
do
for growing up
when i was growing up as a teenager
where i looked i used to have very very
bad acne i had such a big nose my face
was so round we all have acne as kids
don't go to school i would get teased
they would get bullied whenever i was
dating someone they would always
reject me and i always thought that was
just the way i look so i thought okay i
have to change that since i started
having surgeries i'm a totally different
person i used to be a shy
he insecurity it's a good-looking guy no
problem dude
such anxiety now i'm super confident i
can get on stage and sing my songs i can
perform that's why i think plastic
surgery can be a great thing people are
saying look at dr phil's latest
instagram post
okay because you know it can change your
life
okay
what
happened on you just have to see it
i've actually seen this going around on
twitter this morning wait what happened
what happened
i'm just gonna send it right here i got
it uh i got it right here
bro dr phil is out of his mind
what is happening
it says forget where's waldo
find phil found him
yeah
[Music]
what is this situation i uh paid
photoshoots
for dr phil
phil is coming
he's in a
dude feels wild man i don't know but i i
don't know what to say
i don't know what to say
it's a picture of phil in a pool with
you know hundreds of yellow beach balls
looking sinister as hell and his dome
is just glistening clean
all right let's keep watching
[Music]
hey frank what is it
that is so bad about you
that you feel like you need
to be somebody else yeah i mean phil is
so he's so
not just unqualified but his he's he
approaches these issues with bad faith
he he's trying to create drama
what happened
looks like kristen wiig
oh my god yeah right he looks just like
chris dude he transitioned to kristin
wig
he didn't do it intentionally but he did
it
wait wait wait wait wait wait
dude he transitioned to kristen wiig
oh my god
you're so right
that's such a good observation
hey here let me try
you can see it
here you like this one
i feel like you can really see it in
this
and that one
bro he transitioned to kristen wig
the the uh plastic surgery got the wrong
instructions
damn but yeah dr phil approaches [ __ ]
with such bad faith because he doesn't
give a [ __ ] about them he's just trying
to make entertainment it's like
obviously this dude has like body
dysmorphia and like an addiction to
plastic surgery
and
all kinds of [ __ ] issues and it's not
like why aren't you happy with yourself
here
okay well my computer is about to
explode
i feel like there's on yeah i mean
that's awesome
that's so funny
he transitioned
aka dr phil
should i say potato head uh excuse me no
gender on that anymore manufactured
marketed image
i've never seen i was a teenager you
know bro i have never seen anyone that
looks like dr phil in my life like he
has such a unique looking dome
like he's just there's no one else in
the world that looks like dr phil
[Laughter]
dude
this guy's dome is shaped like a rugby
ball
good image
i mean i've i've been unhappy since i
was a teenager you know i used to get
teased at school i used to get bullied
and i moved to career in 2013 and i fell
in love with k-pop fell in love with bts
but it was jimin in particular that
became my absolute obsession so i don't
know i've just never been happy with the
way i looked i was always insecure so i
thought let me change myself and now you
know it's given me so much happiness but
i've i've put myself through a lot of
risks and i do admit that but you're
wanting to
be a uh
clone or a replica
of someone else which is an insult to
you i think it's a tribute to jimin
actually you know it's showing my
appreciation for jimin because i'm so in
love with him i'm so obsessed with it
it's my appreciation for jamin so
i don't think it reflects badly i'm not
losing my who i am still the same person
so this is the closest we found does
this guy pass as phil look at phil dude
that guy's got the craziest dome bro
yeah it's not quite there
that is funny though
oh love sending in a uh
oh saying steve harvey yeah that's kind
of interesting he's like kind of dr
phyllis
yeah
funny they're kind of like
similar vibes
yeah
look right this is my new look the
blonde hair the plastic surgery and i'm
i'm happy like if you look at the
pictures of me and bro that is straight
kmart version like i'm sorry that's like
the best kmart version meme i've ever
seen
or walmart version
oh
my lord
we have jimin at home
exactly that's the best meme ever
no it's true it's true when i was in
korea everyone calls me jimin when i'm
walking down the street everyone's like
oh my god it's james
i know i'm identical
don't leave fabrication people to walk
down the street and say oh that's ollie
i love his music no i love it when they
say germain like trust me it makes me
feel so good because i know i've done a
good job with the surgery i know i've
got the look perfect when everyone calls
me jimin i'm i'm happy nobody has ever
called you that you're looking at me
well people call him jaman it's probably
because he tells people call me jermaine
yeah
and i [ __ ] oop
any good calls here
um tourette's video tory lanez ntf
long distance relationship needs advice
wait real quick jordan peterson cringe
story that's interesting
it's a quick update
okay
wait
really he's just gonna he's just gonna i
don't know throw in the towel it's from
one hour ago well the truth is like i
think he got a rude awakening that he
got his ass rocked by a 40 year old
non-boxing mma fighter
uh he's not going to make a very far in
boxing he could just be trolling though
maybe
maybe it's gonna be like retired boxer
because now i'm an mma fighter the thing
is if he steps like his whole thing has
been like stepping up to more qualified
fighters if he goes up one more step
he will get
and he actually fights like a boxer he
will get hurt
he'll get like actually hurt i think
maybe
and he'll be humiliated
which is such a shame because i'm
actually on board i would i would pay
for another event
to see where
where that happens you know
hope it's not true
i'm not done seeing him get beat up no
i'm serious i wanna yeah i wanna watch
his ass get [ __ ] pulverized
i really do
people are saying more co-host guests
let's see
it's jimin actually
um
people are saying
that yadda yadda
let's keep watching oh jesus
wait i want this jordan pearson cringe
story from joseph
joseph
27 from canada tell me about jordan
peterson i'm fascinated
so i went to the university of toronto
and uh i was waiting around for the
uh one of my classes to start and i was
reading a textbook
so i have a cough i'm actually
recovering from cold unfortunately
but uh so i was reading a textbook on
neuroplasticity and just for a
background i have a condition called
prostagnosia i don't have facial memory
whatsoever
so someone approaching me your family is
like you gotta tell me who you are
because i just don't know it's important
to the story
so a guy comes up to me and he talks and
i immediately recognize his voice
because it's very
comment sounding
and he's talking about the textbook and
why i'm studying psychology ends up
being uh jordan peterson who i'm not
necessarily a huge fan of but i do like
some of his psychology based work i
don't really agree with him on anything
else
so
we start talking and he starts talking
about how psychology is a great uh tool
to solve like existentialism and
nihilism and all these different things
because he's really big on incorporating
different philosophical elements
and he asked me what my favorite
nihilism or existential piece of work is
now i'm not super like
i don't read a whole lot of serious
things but it's school related sure but
i'm not going to waste my time otherwise
and because i'm a big weeb i recommend
uh monster by naoki orosawa super
phenomenal series if you haven't read or
watch it you like anime 1010 recommend
it
he says he's going to look into it and
if i ever see him again we'll talk again
q maybe a week or two later
waiting for class again he walks by he
says he
checked it out
and like he starts criticizing it and i
feel like it was just weird just like to
kind of be like hey you know i know you
like this but here's all the reasons why
it's [ __ ] oh he came to [ __ ] on monster
yeah he just said it was bad and it was
flat and it was on its face and that's
like totally fine and i don't know why i
took it so offensively but i was like
well it's okay if you didn't understand
it
and he had this
look of like shock as if like how do you
not know who i am and how it like
whatever
so hugh you know we talked a little bit
more and he says you know he recommends
me like electron j as if i ever you know
never read that before you're very
typical stuff
now
at the time there was a sort of program
if you were applying for a master's you
were able to show some of your research
in front of a few different professors
if they like it it's kind of like a
sponsorship or scholarship type thing
i'm waiting outside to promote mine and
my associates
and basically we're just waiting outside
the classes to be able to do some stuff
and this man leaves this room uh coming
from where we have to go and he looks at
me
right like look at him back he's got i
know not heads i don't know who this is
i don't have facial memory
he walks back into the class talks for a
bit walks back out nods at me knows me
okay cool he walks away a few minutes
later i get called in we do our entire
research thing we demonstrate it
and they're like yeah you know what
it's not really
it's not really great research it kind
of seems like you didn't know what you
were doing and the empirical data isn't
there and all this kind of stuff and
it's like okay you know i i disagree but
we take it so i didn't really get my
mastership uh urban sorry my master's
scholarship in there
and as i leave my friend is like hey man
jordan peterson was just in that room so
that guy that was leaving and entering
now saw me
probably went back into the room
to just trash talk me or something and
then he left so there's this kind of
overarching name that
in my group that me kind of
calling out jordan peterson for not
understanding it
made him go back into the class
and just kind of say hey there's so much
guy coming up stuff so jordan went out
of his way to trash your work
it can conjecture in so many theories
because i could never verify if that
actually was the person my friend was
the one that pointed out
he spent a lot of time chit chatting
with you so seems like that was a nice
thing for him to do even if he's trashed
her [ __ ]
who is he to criticize monster
he doesn't understand anime
[ __ ]
all right take care buddy
all right love you bye
he's way out of his depth to
pre-criticizing anime
um
i have a thing interesting yes i i have
someone on the line okay uh holy [ __ ]
i'm gonna bring her in right now no
[ __ ] way she messing with me we went
ahead and we verified it we've got id we
had the original
invitation
sent to us for the show
um no [ __ ] way i'm gonna unmute her
right now this is heather
from the winner the winner of the couple
the winner of
of the lord of the flies for a thousand
dollars
holy [ __ ]
have you been watching the whole time
heather
i have i i love to tune in every time
you guys go live i love the show great
okay so wow well um
obviously we had we have some skepticism
about your story
and you know a lot of people in the
comments were saying like well that's
not true actually i work a lot
during high school you want to tell me
about uh
tell me about what we got wrong
yeah so um basically the whole story i
was working at domino's basically full
time i stepped into management when i
was only 16 and i was working like 30
hours a week and
the minimum wage in washington and was
like 12 or something like that so i per
paycheck i was making around
um 500
upwards of 500 per paycheck working
full-time also as a student and
where i live ubers and like lifts are
around like
15 to 20 dollars per ride so for example
in the mornings i'd go to school
15 bucks i'd come back from school
okay so that was your work that was your
hard-earned money
that was all of my hard-earned money and
it went all towards
um rights pretty much because i couldn't
get them from like friends or family so
it was just me and myself and i
well i you know what
[ __ ] hell you did deserve that thawie
i'm sorry for doubting you i think my
life was too privileged and a lot of
people in the comments were saying you
know that's normal
so
[ __ ] dude right and
a lot of the other skepticism that
people had was oh why didn't you take
the bus and a lot of people don't
realize where i live in washington it's
kind of like in a rural area and not a
lot of buses run in my area so i'd have
to actually get a lift to the bus
station and then get on like the three
dollar bus ride and then
having me dropped off like a mile away
from wherever i was going so it was just
really inconvenient i noticed this video
has a lot of views it got like over 10
million views are you getting a lot of
[ __ ] online for this video
um a lot of people yeah uh when it blew
up for like the second time like earlier
this year when it blew up i got a lot of
hate because people just didn't believe
my story there were many of lies that i
used the money to buy like a gucci phone
case or whatever okay we're just making
sure
yeah people were just making [ __ ] up
just to make [ __ ] up with no proof
whatsoever so
rumors got around there just like yeah
she's not using the money for a car and
i did end up getting the car
finally a year later i did end up
getting my first car which
[Applause]
thank you okay so
so
during the show
was stuff cut out because i was
surprised at how supportive everyone was
of you what did the show accurate
accurately represent um
uh what we saw
um i don't remember much from when we
shut the initial video because shooting
was around two hours they cut out a lot
of like the kind of
back story unimportant kind of details
they pretty much put in whatever they
thought would you know make it more
interesting for the viewers and
i
feel like for a lot of the other
cast members like jordan for example a
lot of
her um points were taken out of context
and they kind of made her out to be the
villain
jordan was the bahama girl did you know
pretty much
wait was she she's the bahamas fish girl
yeah she's the bahama girl so you think
they intentionally make edited to make
her look bad that's kind of [ __ ] up to
do to like a young girl
i think so
because a lot of what she said
that wasn't in the video
she was a lot more you know
tame i'd say than how she was kind of
laid out to be in the video how do you
feel now maybe and of course they want
it i'm just kidding you son of a [ __ ]
baby no i'm i'm just going through uh
her social media i feel bad it seems
like did your social media grow up like
blow up after that after the video
it
it did for sure blow up i wasn't
expecting
people to find my social
almost 25k dude but like all of her
posts are like proving what she was
saying was true like she has her uber
received see that's insane i'm sorry
that we doubted you
i feel bad yeah on my instagram there's
a there's like a little highlights
moment where you can see like the q and
a's and i put a lot of my receipts but
basically all my money was going towards
ubers but
yeah
so
do you so did you did you get a thawy or
did they like take half out for taxes
how did that work i'm curious how much
you got in the end
no i did i did end up getting a thousand
dollars but it was kind of
it was weird because
i didn't get the money immediately i i
would kind of had to like keep asking
them like hey where's my money i was
actually i won the thing
so i [ __ ] knew it yeah those
companies are always like that it's like
girls like that it's like i s they gave
me the money because i need it how long
did it take before they actually paid
you
um i think it was like a month because i
just keep sending them emails and like
apparently the lady was like out on like
pregnancy maternity leave and so i had
to get in contact with like a bunch of
other people to get my money but it was
it was a handful and so at the end do
you regret the decision are you happy
you went on there won the though
um
you know in the end i feel pretty
satisfied because i mean that money did
go towards me getting a car and
i just wish i would have explained my
situation a little better because i
wasn't expecting so much too much
backlash for just sharing my story
yeah well to be honest they set that
whole video up to kind of make all you
guys look bad
everybody in the room was convinced
my story i mean everybody in that room
was convinced that you deserved it right
so somehow
there was a disconnect between what the
viewers saw and what the people in the
room understood
yeah there was a huge disconnect all of
the other cast members we got to know
their stories a lot more in depth and
they
ended up cutting a bunch of stuff out
basically
um
well i'm sorry you know what we [ __ ]
up
apologies no it's no worries you were
hating on her i was hating on the other
girl
i did apologize well i apologize to
heather we apologize to heather thank
you i appreciate it olivia
thank you
thank you we're sorry
how are you doing now that you got the
card i appreciate are you in a better
situation now
oh for sure i'm in a totally different
situation i'm i'm living by myself i'm
not working at domino's anymore but i
guess you could say i'm pretty
self-sufficient good for you i can't
prepare myself watch out world
watch out good for you i'm glad
thank you thank you i appreciate you
guys letting me on thanks for calling in
that was pleasant that's awesome it's
really cool to hear from you
what are the odds that she has no so
cool i'm still tripped out by that she's
a legit fan one of her instagram
highlights was her watching frenemies
let's go
oh yeah
big big fan i love the show oh guys are
awesome man
we love heather i love him we love
heather we love you
you know what heather you know what
heather
heather you know what
what's up
give me your email i'm gonna send you a
thousand dollars and i'm gonna send it
tonight
[Applause]
and you tell those [ __ ] that
what was that channel cut
you tell cut
that ethan pays on time
stay online and give you
and give someone your email address or
yeah give me your email address message
me and uh discord okay i should zach
yeah i'm gonna give you
guys
hope you're well thank you i really
appreciate it yeah take care okay enjoy
you deserve it thank you all right take
care thanks heather
thank you bye bye i love that
and we have another big announcement we
do the food's here no heather is the new
co-host oh it's our new show
ladies and gentlemen
and also the food's here which means
it's time to say sayonara
oh
we both hit him with the sayonara
there's no such thing as a coincidence
thanks for watching guys
um
we'll see you on
thursday well for our member your
members will see us wednesday night for
the early release and it off the rails
will be up on thursday for everybody
else
and then yeah starting the following
week you'll be getting
four episodes a week four episodes a
week four episodes a week four episodes
a week four episodes a week all right
let's go
[Music]
so
you